Oh sweet baby Jesus on a pogo stick.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by ting.
Ting is a no bullshit and mobile service.
What does that mean ladies and gentlemen?
What does that mean?
I means Tang eliminates all the shit that's annoying about going to a regular
cell from provider,
but at the same time they give you the same service that you would get if you
had sprint.
Sprint is um,
their backbone.
That's what they use.
So all of their data,
their phone calls,
everything is done through sprint.
But you don't have to deal with contracts.
You don't have any early termination fees,
no bundling or ride along servageon services,
no overages on charges or penalties would.
The Way Tim has it set up is you pay for what you use.
If you use less,
you pay less.
If you use more,
you pay more.
And it,
it all makes sense.
It's real easy to follow.
And I personally believe that it is the model that all cell phone companies will
be forced to adopt in the future.
Contracts are nonsense.
It's gross.
You don't want to use them anymore,
so then all of a sudden you have to pay.
What does this LG flexes as some new shit or phone.
If he says it totally curved,
what have you sit on it the wrong way,
the ship breaks and stuff,
but it's probably good for your front pocket price,
like just curves or ride around your leg.
It probably feels great.
Everybody sideways,
whatever on your cock bag and take a lot of texts.
If you're one of those uh,
Doug Benson characters like Doug,
Doug switched it,
but he used to have it so every time someone would tweet it would show up on his
phone,
his phone with buzz tweeters,
his name,
he fixed that.
He got,
he wised up anyway,
the phones that they do have on Tang,
they're there all the top end android phones,
they,
uh,
Samsung Galaxy note three,
which is what I have.
They have the HTC one,
which is pretty fucking bad ass as well.
They have the,
uh,
the galaxy s four,
which is another outstanding phone.
Tang has basically everything you can need as far as a cell phones,
all the top end android phones and as far as service,
they just cut out all the bullshit and they save a lot of people money.
98% of people would saved money on Ting and if you go to rogan.ting.com you can
save 25 bucks off of any new device.
It is an outstanding cell phone service.
It is a service that many of our friends use and uh,
are very happy with.
I've never had one person complain about it.
Absolutely.
The best android phones that you could buy as well.
All the cool ones.
All the new shit.
Do you think you could do this for a month?
Have one of these flip phones?
Could if I was like one of those contrarion guys,
I was hanging around with a bunch of old dudes and Dallas,
this old karate guys and they all had flip phones was hilarious.
Yeah.
Chuck Norris is a fucking flip phone.
Chuck Norris.
So I flipped open his phone.
Bob Wall from enter the Dragon.
We'll flip phone.
I think there is something nice too about the idea of it only being a phone
dynamic examiner razor right now.
Yeah,
it was to have a razor in your pocket,
but it's also nice to be able to do everything from one device and texts and all
that.
Imagine if you had one phone and then you had to someone in a dress and then you
can send me the contact information.
Uh,
Shit.
You can't copy paste.
You can't do anything.
Fuck all that man.
That's just the past.
You don't want to have a carrier pigeon either.
All right.
Fuck a smoke signal.
That's what I'm saying.
Brian.
Fuck a smoke signal.
You heard me?
I'm controversial.
I don't know about to sell GE flex though.
I don't know.
It might be cool.
It might be annoying too.
It seems cool.
I as I like to see,
I think eventually they're going to have roll up phones.
I mean it's gonna be like a scroll.
You got parchment to hear you hear you.
Are you going to roll out your phone?
It's gonna be one of those flip bracelets at the kids.
Where have you ever seen it?
Where it's like a big metal thing that you can tap on rounds.
Albrey has a,
I'm one of those electric cars.
When I was Teslas I thought those things were nonsense until I got in one holy
shit is that they have the dopest screen I've ever seen in a car.
It's the whole front thing is a screen like the panel in the middle.
I did.
Does the air conditioning the radio?
It's a giant computer screen dude.
It's pretty weird.
Shit freezes up your whole car.
Yeah,
your car is probably going to crash for sure.
Yeah.
And if there's any sort of electrical like shortage or anything like that.
Some,
if your car gets hit by lightning it's toast.
What is that first year model?
That's crazy.
I think it's a,
they've had cars before cause they had the Tesla sports car,
which was also a battery controlled car.
But that was a tricky car because all the batteries were in the ass end of the
car and he's a really light car so it's like one of those old Porsche's.
The old Porsche's have the engine hanging out back and it changes the dynamics
of the handling.
Like when you go round corners the asset and wants a pop around,
it's called oversteer.
Like some people like it.
It's kind of fun to drive like that,
but you have to get used to it and know what it's going to do.
If you're used to driving a regular car and you used to like go in sideways and
like a corvette or something like that and you'd be getting one of those things,
it's a very different sort of a dynamic.
They look cool though.
You seen those little plot,
the little plastic thing.
They look like little fun matchbox cars.
They look like a little lotus.
That's what they look like.
And uh,
apparently they're pretty fast too.
Uh,
and all electric,
you know,
which cool.
In La you could actually really do it electrically because you could have solar.
It's charging your car.
I mean a lot of people have that now where they have just a solar charger to
their car so their is not hooked up to the grid at all.
Wow.
Yeah.
Pretty wicked.
Has nothing to do with tango,
rogan.ting.com go get yourself some bitches.
It's uh,
an awesome cell phone service and we love them.
We're also brought to you by on at.com it's o.
N,
n.
I.
T.
If you have not been to on it,
then you obviously are not optimized.
Bitch.
What does that mean?
What does it mean?
It means that's what art is about.
Ana is a human optimization website.
W that's a nice way of saying we sell shit that makes your body work better.
Whether it's strength and conditioning equipment,
whether it's supplements like hemp protein powder or foods rather like can't
protein powders or supplements like new mood or shroom tech sport or uh,
any of the products that we provide,
we things that we
use that we think help you work better.
Whether it's things like kettle bells or battle ropes or whether it's a
different kinds of supplements and healthy snacks.
We started selling these new things called warrior bars.
They're fucking awesome.
They're made out of buffalo and cranberry and an ancient native American recipe.
It's no antibiotics,
no added hormone,
completely gluten free.
And it gets,
gives you 14 grams of protein in each serving and they're fucking delicious.
It's,
it's literally a no guilt snack.
It tastes yummy with no MSG,
no nitrates,
no antibiotics or added hormones.
Super Awesome for you and tastes delicious.
And we said we just try to sell you shit.
That's cool.
Anything that we find that's good.
Find the finest hemp protein powder available that we bring in from Canada
because our corrupt politicians won't let American farmers make some cash.
That's how we roll.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com o.
N N.
I t.
Use the codeword Rogan.
Save 10% off any and all supplements.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Shane Smith is here.
Why fuck around any longer?
Oh,
we have a show Friday night at the Ice House.
It's called Thunderpussy.
And a,
if you've never been to a Thunderpussy show is not a regular comedy show would
get a bunch of fucking
with Thunderpussy.
Is is,
it's a show where no one plans what they're going to say.
Everyone goes onstage,
fucked up,
the audience calls out ideas and everyone just starts talking shit.
Sometimes it's awesome.
But last time it was awesome.
It's cool because it's a unique comedy show.
You,
you'll never see another like these comics doing these bits because they're just
making them up on the fly while they're on stage.
Yeah.
And you can't,
you can't come on stage with some fucking material.
That's one of the roles.
You're not allowed to do that.
We'll get any material.
That's a joke you wrote that you weak bitch.
Uh,
it's a lot of fun.
and I'll be there.
And Eleanor Kerrigan,
Jeremiah Watson,
rob Gleason,
Omar Nava.
I don't know who that is,
but I liked the name.
A lot of people,
a lot of fun people.
Jason Rouse,
rouse,
he's the one that he did that,
that website contest that we had and he was so like wanting to win like every
day you checked with music did I went to,
what did it go those,
the Squarespace website contest,
those,
those are fucking dope websites.
Uh,
there was too many websites.
So bunch of people should've won that contest.
We should add a hundred winners anyway.
Uh,
ice house Friday night.
And it's the little room
to the,
which is like 90 seats.
Really sweet spot to hang out.
All right.
That's it on at.com.
Codeword Rogan Thunderpussy Friday night.
Uh,
that's it.
Everything else.
Go to Joe rogan.net for all my tour dates.
I got a lot of shit coming up in Miami.
April 3rd.
I'm in Miami Bitch.
Orlando April 18th with Joey Diaz and then Baltimore on the 25th of April also
with Joey Diaz.
All right.
That's it kind of prompts.
Well,
good experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
World traveler,
internationally known,
locally accepted bad mother fucker out doing ridiculous shit all over the world
and not slowing down anytime soon.
Are you the new Rupert Murdoch?
Keep hearing you're the new Rupert Murdoch.
What does that mean?
I don't know why I keep coming on here.
Shit.
Oh,
I love you.
I love it.
I love,
uh,
I love everybody in.
No,
I know.
I'm not the next week.
What's the latest man?
Where the fuck have you been?
Neat.
Where are you getting back from?
Every time I've emailed you or talk to you or Twitter or text message and you're
in the middle of fucking nowhere and some dark places.
You're so funny.
We were talking before the show and he's like,
yeah,
I should get you to do some of these things.
I can send you the North Pole.
Like,
bitch,
I'm not going to the fucking North Pole.
You don't know me man.
Good one though.
Easy one.
What are you saying?
The North Pole is not good or easy.
That's ridiculous.
It's polar bears up there,
right?
And there's polars is a salt south pole pole arose.
Which one is programs or North Pole.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So one of them has penguins,
one of them does it.
South Poles,
penguin,
north pole doesn't polar bear.
Why would that possibly be easy?
Well
it's a bitch to get to because you have to like fly thousand times and then go,
you know,
with a sled and dogs and ice helicopters and Shit and whenever she,
but a,
it's a,
it's a crazy story.
What's going on there?
That's like a,
you know,
world war three happening up there.
So this is the place where what's going on in,
in the middle of the North Pole now.
So the ice is melting,
right?
And,
and a that's leading to two things.
One opening up of passages so Russians can come right across,
which is great because now it looks like we're going back to the Cold War,
but,
um,
it's also just tons of oil.
Tons of minerals can now be sort of,
you know,
mind because the environment,
Isis will just fuck it up even more.
So what's happening is everyone's amassing huge,
uh,
sort of caches of arms.
So,
uh,
you know,
the Russians obviously are getting up there.
Everyone's planting flags on the seabed floors.
This is ours.
No,
this is ours.
So the scan,
these are trying to get in their candidates trying to get in there.
Both are being destroyed by the Russians and the Americans,
Chinese are in there.
Everybody's getting there with subs,
you know,
uh,
lots of naval naval buildup,
but huge arms buildup going on there because that's going to be the next sort
of,
uh,
not only the,
the sort of transportation routes,
but also,
you know,
all the sort of natural minerals,
rare earth minerals,
oil,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Essentially it's just like when the Bering straight back during the ice age is
connecting the United States to Asia and then it went away.
Yeah.
Now new passages
like that are opening up.
Correct.
So the whole North Pole is melting,
so you can,
what's happening now is you can actually,
you know what,
when a lot of the earlier explorers we're trying to get to China by going around
the north and now that's opening up.
So it's opening up north of,
of,
of Scandinavia so that Russia can actually go right around Scandinavia because
they never really had it fresh water year round port.
And so that's a big deal for them.
Um,
but you know,
same thing for Canada,
the same thing for the states.
China.
They're all trying to get up there and lay sort of rights to all the minerals
and all the oil.
It's up there as well as the passage.
How does that work?
Like who decides who owned that since it's really,
what was it before it was an international waters?
That was it.
Well,
yeah.
I mean people had laid claim to it,
but you couldn't know any went there.
So who the hell cares?
You know,
what does it matter?
You couldn't get through because it was all iced up.
So now what's happening is a massive land grab.
People are just planning their flags and saying,
no,
this is ours now.
This is not yours.
This is our,
and they're sort of fighting it out.
But basically up there might makes,
right?
So if I got my ships up there,
I got my guns up there,
I got my air force up there,
guess what?
It's mine.
Wow.
And it's so fascinating how over the last few years they've discovered all these
massive,
massive supplies of oil up,
huge reserves of oil,
shale oil,
and all weird oil that you have to fucking,
but what's the,
what's the kind of in Utah that they found where you have to burn it and it
creates all this horrible carbon's being emitted into your environment in order
to process?
Yeah,
there's all different,
I mean the worst oil that they have for the environment is in Canada is the tar
sands where they have to take all the fresh water,
boil up the sand to get out the oil boiler,
you know,
to get the oil out costs tons and tons of money and whatever.
But because the oil so expensive now that it's become economically feasible,
why?
And that's the stuff that pollutes the environment pretty heavily.
Well,
it all does,
but I mean tar sands,
it's shocking.
It's like really,
really bad.
I think that's what they were talking about in Utah.
I'm not sure what they're,
they're trying to figure out a way it'd be tar sands.
They found more oil in Utah are ready for this then humans have ever used ever.
So there's no way you're going to keep those fucking dirty criminals from
pulling out of the ground.
I'm fucking up everything.
I mean,
if it's tar sand,
I don't know about Utah specifically.
I know about candidates very,
very bad because they take the whole La Lake Athabaska sort of uh,
a watershed and they use the water to boil out the,
the,
the oil,
and then you have all of this sort of chemical sand that they have to chuck.
You have all the water's destroyed.
And then obviously you've got the oil.
It's oil shale.
That's a good thing.
Yeah.
Shale.
That's,
so that is shale oil.
Yeah.
Well
that's what you got it.
There's,
there's,
you got to go down and there's fracking to get natural gas in this fracking and
blowing up to get the shallow,
well,
there is a lot of that shit out there apparently.
It's interesting that they're just finding this over the last decade or so.
They knew about it,
but it was too expensive.
It wasn't,
it wasn't economically viable.
But now because it's $100 a barrel,
they're like fuck,
blow the shit out of everything.
So they knew about it and Utah too,
they knew about all these ones.
They knew that you could get it.
Oh fracking isn't anything new.
Right.
You know,
uh,
oil sands,
tar sands or anything new.
Cheryl is a new,
it's just,
Oh you know,
we can,
it's now economically viable tax and get this shit out.
Cause it was too expensive before.
It's the same thing was using co two and water to sort of,
you know,
frack or to pump out the rest of the oil and wells cause we didn't get all the
oil out before,
only what was pressurized.
There's a thing that comes up when you talk about anything that causes some sort
of environmental hazard where you have two different types of people that
automatically jump on the argument.
There's the type of people that are like,
oh my God,
we have to save Alz and all of the trees or whatever the fuck his growing up
there.
And then there's these other people,
these other people that almost universally like are not financially successful
but support hardcore republican ideals,
including like the sacrificing of the environment for it,
for some sort of an economic gain.
I don't understand.
Stand
it.
And I just did a piece on Greenland that's going to be airing on our HBO show
tomorrow.
And I've been doing a lot of press around.
It's interesting cause I did a piece on sea level rise last season and generally
about 90% of our comments are like,
you guys fucking rock.
It was great.
And then there's 10% and 80% of the comments all of a sudden on the
environmental stuff were negative.
And I was like,
how's this even happening?
And there was a,
uh,
like a,
a study was done that if the first four comments on an environmental thing or
any,
uh,
like news piece are negative,
then people negate the,
the,
the actual piece.
So they spent hundreds of millions of dollars for bloggers and people to just go
out and do comments so that anything launches,
they sit there and they,
and they,
they,
you know,
say that this is bad or not true,
whatever.
For me,
look,
here's the deal.
You know,
when I talked to scientists all the time,
uh,
for this,
Green Line piece,
I talked to the chief climatologists that NASA and I said,
okay,
so how,
how,
how much of this is,
is manmade?
Cause I went to Greenland and it's melting and,
and,
and in Greenland is going to melt and it's 24 feet of sea level rise.
So if the sea level rises is 24 feet,
then 80% of the world's cities go under water.
So I said,
okay,
you know,
how much of this is manmade?
And he's,
he's,
he's a conservative scientist.
He's like a NASA guy.
He's not like some crazy tree hugging and guy.
And he's like,
well,
100% of it.
I said,
hold on.
What do you mean 100% of them?
It was just natural.
It was,
it's 100% like if you look at it,
and I actually,
when I was talking to him,
he's like,
if we cut our carbon emissions by 80% it's still going to continue for the next
500 years.
Global warming,
but,
or at least,
but we just slowed down the pace of it.
And I'm like,
well how long,
you know,
how much of Greenland is going to melt?
He goes,
well all of it,
it's just a question of how fast is it going to be?
500 years,
it can be 50 years is going to be,
you know,
150 years.
And so I actually kind of got mad at the scientists cause I'm like,
he's,
he's saying this as if it's boring.
And I'm saying,
hold on,
this is the global scientific consensus.
And then I'm like,
well people in America don't understand that.
I don't understand that.
And I do this for a living that,
you know,
because we did a thing on the Texas drought because we,
there was a drought here in California.
Everybody's like global warming,
global warming.
And in Texas,
they've had a drought for three years and they denied climate change.
Like Rick Perry has said,
it's not true,
the governor of the state.
And then you sit there and say,
okay,
well how is that possible?
So we went to talk to people and they're like,
yeah,
climate change has been denied.
I mean it's,
it's been disproven.
And,
and,
and that I find insidious because they know it's not true.
The,
the fossil fuel companies.
No,
it's not true.
The car companies.
And though it's not true,
the politicians,
no,
it's not true.
They know what the global,
uh,
consensus is the scientific consensus.
And yet they,
they,
they fund and,
and,
and say that it's not happening.
And that's bad because they're fucking all of humanity and the future of
humanity for,
for short term profits.
And that's what's insidious about climate change denial.
It's very insidious.
And it's very fascinating to me.
This play on these people,
these no nonsense type people.
There's a mentality that people adopt where they don't want to be fools.
Right?
And it's the no nonsense mentality.
And I've,
I've documented this,
this is like something that I've really been studying for quite a while.
There's people that in spite of all the evidence in front of them,
they want to believe the official story on almost everything and almost always
take the conservative viewpoint.
And a lot of times that conservative viewpoint is who they are,
the very type of people who they are,
it's against them and yet they still support it.
A lot of them are hard working blue collar people and they have this idea that
somehow or another in the future,
they want to be able to make money freely.
So,
you know,
I don't want the government stepping in and stopping all this shale because I
could step in and maybe do a little shale mine and myself and start making
millions of dollars.
And right now they're not.
Right now they're the ones who are being punished by a lot of these ideas that
pushing forth themselves.
It's very strange.
But
if you ever talked to,
and I agree with you,
and I always found it incredibly confusing,
and we just did this story on,
on vets returning from Afghanistan and Iraq and how they're overprescribed
overmedicated oh yeah.
By the Va.
It's a huge problem.
What's working folks who support big business?
Well that's it.
And,
and,
and if you talk to the disillusioned veterans veterans,
of which I have tremendous respectful,
by the way,
but coming back from these wars that were fought for economic reasons,
for oil,
and,
and when they realize that,
they're like,
oh,
we were duped,
you know,
the,
we went over there to fight the good fight.
There is no,
it does no good.
It's no good fight.
We went over there to fight for oil.
And by the way,
there's never been a good fight.
Right?
I mean,
look,
you could say World War II,
you know,
and that's his bad.
Yeah,
no,
very bad people.
You know,
I would say that Iraq now is,
is pretty much a given.
There were no weapons of mass destruction.
He wasn't even doing anything without God.
It was a secular regime.
They were enemies.
We went in to get oil.
And I think,
you know,
if you look at Afghanistan now,
we just did a piece on Afghanistan and to Taliban and running,
uh,
south Afghanistan and the northern lights are running northern Afghanistan.
And the minute we pull out,
it's going to be the Taliban take over the south just like they did before.
And $1 trillion in hundreds of thousands of lives are just going to be wasted
for nothing because alcaide is going to be in with the Taliban again,
which is why we went in there in the first place.
So anyway,
not that what I'm trying to get at is I think that a lot of the mentality,
you know,
people are used for economic purposes and that I find insidious people should
not be,
it is not just insidious,
it's,
it's maddening because a lot of those people who really signed up to serve their
country,
correct.
Real legit heroes.
Correct.
And they were used.
And if you go back and read Smedley butlers,
war is just a racket from 1930 something.
He was a major brigadier major general character.
I forget what his exact title and rank was,
but he was a well respected military man and spelt,
it's whole life and the service of the country.
And then realized when he was retiring that he only existed to go out there and
make sure things were safe for bankers,
clear the air for oil manufacturers,
whatever it was that he was really doing.
He thought he was over there,
you know,
promoting freedom.
Sure.
Keeping America safe.
And he wrote this a fascinating and very damning piece,
and this isn't in the 1930s so it's always been like that.
It's always been this double hustle that even the people involved in it don't
realize they're a part of the hustle,
the very most important part to machine.
The hammer itself doesn't realize it's part of the hustle.
The very guys pulling the trigger.
Well,
if they were,
if they realize that they wouldn't,
they wouldn't go fight.
It's so insidious that you could figure out a way to get someone to do that.
And the way you get them to do that is actually get them to love their country.
I can actually get real heroes.
Wow.
You know,
you're,
you're preying off patriotism.
It's that thing too though,
man,
that I'm a good person and I'm a no nonsense,
good person.
And that's the same shit that gets prayed upon with this whole global warming
denial thing.
Well,
I don't understand because whenever I talk to someone,
I'm like,
okay,
I'm a gambling guy.
You know,
I,
you know,
even if it's a 1% chance,
so you're so sure it's 100% sure it's 100% it's a fucking hoax.
Right?
What if it's 1%?
What if it's 5% what if it's 10% don't you want to fucking hedge your bet?
Well and say,
because total global economic or sorry,
environmental disaster and breakdown versus,
okay,
we're all okay,
don't you want to hedge your bet?
Wouldn't you want to hedge your bet against a complete,
uh,
environmental disaster?
I would.
I'm a gambling man.
I'll bet 1% to,
to say,
okay,
it's like insurance when you play back.
Right?
Or,
or,
or when they've got a 21.
Okay,
I'll,
you know,
I'll take that insurance because even if it's 1% true,
I'm convinced it's 100% true,
but even if it's 1% you don't,
you want to hedge your bet.
I think it's a confirmation bias issue that these ideas fit into there no
nonsense mentality.
The no nonsense mentalities,
almost like a,
it's almost like a religion.
It's come on,
Oswaldo acted alone.
Stop.
It was the same guy.
Like they're not even looking into it.
They just go with this no nonsense idea.
Even in the face of it
all sorts of Wa.
It's interesting in Texas and,
and,
and because you have a,
a loss of a whole way of life because all the cows are dying.
They've had a three year drought.
They've either sold them off where they've died and so you sit there and say,
okay,
in the face of all your fucking cattle,
which was Texas for the longest period of time,
you know,
dying because of this prolonged drought.
Now you have people who were like incredible deniers and people saying,
no,
that's not true.
Saying,
actually,
there might be something to this shit and I don't know what it is,
but we got to look into it and we can't just pray for fucking rain anymore.
There's been congress,
there was a Republican congressmen that we talked to who said like,
I was just a climate change denier because Al Gore was for it,
therefore I was again.
And then when I did the research,
I realized,
Holy Shit,
this is,
there's,
there's something to this.
And he got drummed out of the party and lost a seat.
Wow.
And,
and look,
it's,
uh,
it's big political business down there and it's an oil state.
It's an oil state now because there's no more cattle.
So there all the water,
they have no water for the cattle they're using for fracking.
So you sit there and you say,
look,
you know,
it's,
it's gotten so bad now that even people who have been deniers for so long are
saying,
you know what?
Fuck,
okay,
what the fuck are we going to do?
Have you seen the photos of,
I think it's Lake Travis Travis.
It's not down to nothing.
There's like boats that were like sitting on the shore in front of these
people's a million dollar estates and now these things are in the middle of this
field.
It's like there's grass growing up.
I mean,
it's not going.
And by the way,
that's green Texas.
Yeah,
Texas is,
yeah,
you're right.
Nobody raped.
That's Austin.
You know,
we're talking about Austin,
which is,
you know,
is it about,
is a Rainey's against like we do that.
That's,
that's a kind photograph that's happening in California as well.
We were a at lake to hone and lake to hone.
Used to have some of the best bass fishing in northern cal and southern
California.
That is a great spot.
They had this great there,
right?
It was just filled with large mouth bass and it's a private,
um,
the,
the whole,
um,
ranch 270,000 acres is private,
so he couldn't just get in there to fish.
So they would let people come in and fish keep the employees would fish.
Like people would pay to fish there.
It's fucking gone.
Now.
It's gone.
Almost all the fish are dead.
The water's like six inches deep.
Like you can walk across the entire lake.
Now,
question for you.
When that happens,
when lakes are disappearing,
Lake Travis to disappear,
all these plays are disappearing and people still say,
fuck you Joe.
It's fucking natural.
Occurrence of things is bullshit.
There's no climate change.
Fuck you.
What do you say to them?
Well,
the guy,
the last guy that I had a conversation with,
they told me that it was just a natural cycle.
He's a guy from Jujitsu and I was like,
you know,
I said,
well,
there's always been natural cycles.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's true.
You know,
there's the,
the climate on the earth is varied widely,
but it doesn't mean that human intervention,
what we've caused can't play a big part in accelerating that and accelerating it
and unmanageable way.
And he didn't really have an answer to that cause he wasn't,
no,
not skin.
He was a no nonsense guy.
He was just a young military kid who has this idea in his head that,
you know,
there's a lot of hippy bullshit being flown around there without about the
environment.
Well,
I think that's the problem.
You know,
Al Gore made $1 billion telling everybody that he's the first green billionaire
general know that.
Okay.
It doesn't mean totally right.
Well,
the interesting thing about Al Gore and I find it very interesting,
not that I,
I'm an Al Gore lover.
I uh,
I came up actually hating a tipper Gore cause uh,
she was censorship,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
All the rap lyrics.
She exactly,
exactly.
And uh,
but you got to look at Al Gore and say he wasn't,
uh,
like a big l liberal.
He was like a sort of sense using tobacco guy from the south.
Like,
you know,
centrist,
in,
in most countries in the world,
he'd be sort of center,
right?
Conservative dude.
He came out of politics being an environmentalist.
Now he didn't do that mate.
Oh,
I don't know.
I May,
I don't know the guys very well,
but you know,
he came out freaking out about the environment.
Why?
Because all the shit that he learned in politics,
all the behind the scenes shit that we don't know about,
freaked him out so much that he said,
I'm going to actually go out and do this movie and say the environment is
fucked.
Hey,
by the way,
this isn't like Greenpeace dude,
this hippie,
this is a tobacco southern dude,
conservative dude,
no conservative in America,
but you know,
whatever conservative in the world.
And he comes down and says the environment's fucked.
What's interesting is he wins Nobel Prize,
does a good movie,
all this stuff,
but then gets vilified to the point that now Al Gore is a joke.
And when we say,
Oh,
you know,
fuck it.
You know he's this and it's Al Gore.
And,
and by the way,
isn't that a great fucking triumph for four deniers?
Because there's like Al Gore's,
and I would joke for doing a movie that says,
Hey,
by the way,
the environment's fucked.
Yeah.
Isn't that weird that they can do that,
that they can turn to like,
he's almost like,
remember when Richard Gere Ead,
say Richard Gray thought dribble up the ass.
Right?
That's all anybody thought.
Yeah.
Well when you talk about Al Gore now,
especially around certain circles,
he's a joke when it comes to the climate,
is there anything that he said that was debunked or was it all bullshit?
No,
they just,
they kept attacking him,
attacking him,
attacking you.
And by the way,
it's a fat.
It's fascinating because what there is is anyone says anything we don't like,
we attack their character and once we attack their character and their on the
defensive,
then we fucking won.
Yeah.
Cause then it's not about what they said.
It's about well fucking this person.
We can't trust what he said because he liked to finger up his ass.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And that is a fascinating thing they do with comments on videos like especially
your kind of documentaries that,
and they attack and it's been proven now.
I mean those are part of the Snowden deal.
We actually got to see fact that they spend money on what propaganda trying to
influence.
They'd go to websites,
message boards,
they go to social chat,
they go on Twitter.
There's a lot of people that I've got another question for you.
Okay.
Why isn't there more fucking outrage about the NSA listening to every fucking
phone call,
every tweet,
every fucking email,
every,
every everything and saying,
we live in a goddamn police state.
We signed away where we never even signed it away,
but our,
our,
our rights and freedoms and I look,
I came to this country because it's land of the free home of the brave.
Fuck a beautiful country.
I love it here.
Gorgeous place.
Why is it there?
More outrage at the NSA watching everything we do and doing it a,
I think there is outrage,
but I think people feel like they are waiting for something to happen and they
don't know what they can do about it.
They don't feel like they have any real legitimate power.
They can express their outrage.
They wait for the politicians to make some announcements.
And I mean,
what is the only thing that Obama said that they're going to try to slow it down
somewhat or do something differently in some,
in some way.
What are you doing?
I'm blocking his face.
Oh fuck all those people.
You can't listen to those people out there.
Those people
I didn't know we were on the TV.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't worry about all those people.
They complain too much.
They've,
and they love it if you react to them.
I'm a ghost producer.
I like looking at him hiding.
I,
that's why I feel like it's enough for his job
sneaking around behind things and reporting on the reality of the situation.
Um,
where were we?
What were we just talking?
And I say NSA being a horrible,
I'm so scared.
I'm like,
to me are,
they just don't know what to do.
They're in this holding pattern waiting for something to happen.
Cause I got to tell you what,
like
that's just bad.
It's going getting worse.
And,
and,
and we,
you know,
we just did this interesting story in Camden,
New Jersey.
No,
no,
calm,
right?
No cops,
Yeah.
They run out of money for cops.
So yeah.
So highest crime rate,
highest murder rate ran out of money for cops.
So what did they do?
They hired like a tech company to come in and they put cameras everywhere,
hidden microphones,
and they can try and you like the gunshot sounds and they got cameras everywhere
and they know where everybody is.
So like,
Oh yeah,
we know this guy,
we know where he's going and he's probably going to commit a crime,
so we're going to pick him up.
It's like,
what's that Tom Cruise movie minority report.
Like they've figured it out like,
well,
everything before it's going to happen.
But,
but I'm like,
hold on.
As I'm watching it,
I'm like,
that's not even the scary part.
That's pretty scary.
But they have recorded and filmed everything that's going on in that fucking
town 24 hours a day.
They know everything that's going on there.
Right.
And you're,
and it's been such a success.
It really just put it underground,
but whatever.
It's been a success because the crime rate drop that Chicago,
New York,
all these big cities are doing it now.
So not only are you going to have the NSA listening to your phone calls and
you're a fucking,
you know,
whatever your social media,
everything.
But you're going to be filmed and listened to everywhere you go.
And if that,
that's not 19 that makes 1984 look like a fucking,
you know,
children's fairy tale,
that's,
you're always going to be watched every fucking thing that you ever do.
If that's not the definition of a police state,
I don't know what it is.
No.
It's most certainly the definition of a police state.
And it's almost inevitable because of the expanding reach of technology.
Correct.
Once they have the ability to send drones everywhere they want to,
they're going to have drones that are,
the size of bugs,
are going to have HD capability.
You're a smart dude because I was just at this tech conference,
uh,
and,
and w as all these CEOs in this thing,
and we were talking about it and I would got into a fight with one of these big
dudes.
They're an old dude,
big powerful guy.
And he said,
you know who,
who,
who wouldn't a jail?
Snowden.
And I said,
me,
I wouldn't tell them.
What's the difference between Snowden and Woodward and Bernstein,
Woodward and Bernstein and the presidential papers,
like they were the punks of their generation,
like,
but now they're heroes because it's the baby boomers and Snowden's fuck you.
It's what's good for the goose is good for the Gander.
Anyway,
we got into this fight.
What's he,
what's his argument,
you know?
Well,
I didn't,
he was just,
he's bad and has whatever the same argument,
no
country
in front of them.
And so,
and so,
you know,
we got into this fight,
but,
but uh,
you know,
the interesting thing about that is a,
the fact that a lot of people,
you know,
whistleblowing is seen as unaware.
I,
I see it as,
as that's what's going to keep democracy safe,
but this sort of overreaching.
And I said,
look,
you know,
I didn't come to America for it to be,
to live in a police state and this is the definition of a police state is that
they can watch everything that we do.
And it was all these tech guys and the tech guys just sort of rolled their eyes
and said,
it's already happened.
The tech is already there.
The,
the government has already made the deals.
It's a defacto thing.
You can't change it and then,
then I got kind of worried because you're exactly right.
You're 100% right.
The tech is so pervasive that you can't fuck with it.
Well,
there's also a future tech that they're working on that is essentially tiny wifi
powered cameras that are the size of grains of sand.
Sure.
And they're going to scatter that.
Yeah,
there is scatter them all throughout cities and they will literally have access
to video,
audio,
everything from these grains of sand.
It'll be all over the beaches.
Tune into them.
They,
they like,
if you go to Camden,
it's already happened.
That's the whole scary thing.
It was like,
this isn't like toads have battled,
this isn't science.
It isn't science fiction anymore.
They,
they can hear,
they can triangulate sound from any point in the city.
Like inside houses,
like anywhere they can,
they can listen to try anything and you're just like,
holy fuck.
Like for those of us who get up to some nefarious activities,
that's not great news.
Well,
even not so nefarious activities like people who like the fucking public,
you know,
have you seen that video?
There's a video these to this coupled on Saint Patrick's day.
They were banging behind a dumpster and uh,
these people drove by and got video of it,
put the video online and now the cops are looking for these people.
I go,
you good news.
You save us from the bad people that look to fuck.
But that's a problem.
Okay,
so now we have information from about everybody at all time.
What are we going to do with that information?
You know,
that some bureaucrat,
major general captain,
some bullshit artists is going to be sitting besides behind some computer things
saying,
you know what?
I think that's bullshit.
I'm going to fucking take that guy.
Wait,
that's a police state.
That can't happen.
Yeah,
it,
well,
it's kind of unfortunate,
but then then democracy goes out the fucking window.
I think it goes out the window.
Anyway,
I think it's got to shift.
It's going to shift this turning into a depressing,
no,
it's not.
But here's the issue.
Because what's going to happen is the same thing that has sort of happened with
cellulite.
I mean,
obviously I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Just as a caveat here,
what's going to happen is the same thing that's happening with cellular
communication.
At one point in time,
cellular communication was a giant brick that you had to hang on to it.
So you used to have a fucking suitcase,
carry it around with them and hold them in your,
and now you can go to the Amazon and people have cell phones.
You can go to the poor third world countries and people have south.
Correct.
I think that right now the information,
the access to all this stuff,
the ability to know what's going on everywhere all the time is terrifying to us
because we don't possess it.
The only people that possess it or the people like the NSA or the people that
are monitoring Camden,
eventually that technology will become so pervasive.
It will be like Wikipedia.
It'll be like everything else.
It'll be all the time and you will have no privacy,
but they will have
no privacy either.
You know we going to have privacy.
The one I don't believe that.
I believe the rich will have privacy because there'll be able to pay for tech
that can protect them.
They'll try new shit will come up.
You know,
you're going to know you're going to have a phone,
they're gonna know where your phone is going to have an internet connection.
Blocking technologies might take it to another place.
I just think it's going to get even crazier than that cause I think that when I
extrapolate,
when I get,
when I get really high,
and I think about this,
especially when I get into the tank,
I come in to this one conclusion and this one conclusion is that money and its
current form is not resource base.
The economy is essentially based on confidence and numbers.
Well that's just information and in a certain point in time technology is going
to hit that it's going to hit a bottleneck and that bottleneck is going to be
money.
The bottleneck is that technology as it progresses,
the trend seems to be in a more immediate access to information and a easier
connection between people.
Well that's going to come to a point where there's one thing that's shielded one
piece of information that shield,
and that's going to be money.
We're not going to know.
What are your thoughts on Bitcoin?
Well,
the,
I think that's a part of it.
I think that's just one part of it.
You know,
I think bitcoin is being for sure tampered with for sure.
Fucked with.
I think all these people,
like this guy that had the Mt Gox and fucking $300 million goes away and it's
crashed.
That is most likely a bunch of things,
I'm sure.
And competence.
Shitty programming probably sabotage.
Let's be honest on these.
Really thought that it's possible for a new currency to come along.
Antonopoulos coming back on again.
Yeah.
He's coming back on soon in April.
Um,
w without a doubt someone would step in and try to do that.
Why would they not try to do that?
What they're going to just sit by and twiddle their thumbs and hope that their
money's good enough to compete.
Get the fuck Outta here.
These are criminals.
These are fucking swashbucklers and Buccaneers.
They're assholes.
They're digital Buccaneers and just like the same people send people out to
diminish climate reports by leaving shitty comments,
they're going to also go after bitcoin any way they can.
Did you hear about this Silk Road Shit that her,
yes,
yes.
Yeah.
Anything on that?
We're doing a film on the till you tell people folks,
you don't know what Silk Road is.
Tell them what it is and what happened.
Well,
I'm not the biggest expert in the world.
We're doing a film on it and uh,
and,
and so I only know the sort of pitch versions.
What's a website?
It's,
it's,
it's a,
yeah,
it's a website.
It's a,
it's a,
it was a service that was the dark web.
The,
you know,
a lot of shit went down.
And basically where they made their money was it was a door to door drug dealing
service where they made the majority of their cash and it was high quality.
They guaranteed the quality and,
and you could,
you didn't have to leave your house and someone would come and they would take
us sort of charge on both sides,
like deliver coke.
And to your house.
Correct.
Anything?
Anything.
It was like dark web,
sort of a Craig's list.
Well,
this is where it gets interesting is the guy who started,
he started,
it was like 21 years old.
He said like this nice kid,
whatever.
Apparently in really nice kid and they,
they,
they talked to his parents and shit.
They're like,
well now he's living in the North Pole with your fucking reporters hiding under
a Naglu.
Now he's now he's 20 stories down and he's dead.
And the CIA building.
No,
they got him.
They got him.
You out.
Here's the story.
This is my favorite part is this young kid,
right?
He sets up Silk Road,
which is basically a sort of peer to peer,
whatever the fuck you want to have happen on the,
on the,
on the second economy,
a lot of drugs but basically drugs.
But yes,
there was arms.
Anything sort of illegal was going on,
was going through this thing.
Now what happened was,
you know,
very sin,
a sin,
a graphics cinemagraphic moment.
He's in a public library,
right?
Using the public Wifi.
He's running the whole thing from his laptop and they know if he,
if he closes the laptop it will be encrypted and then it's a brick and he's
fucked.
So the whole,
everyone in the library,
the person looking at the books,
the library and the,
you know,
the freaky dude sleeping in the court and they're all fucking FPI right.
And they're all watching this kid.
He's like,
you know,
really young guy as he's running this silk road thing.
And they had to get him before he closed his laptop.
So he literally stood up to like grab something and they just,
the whole library went into motion and they got them.
Now what they found out was he was just a guy trying to run a business.
He's like,
okay,
you know,
you bring the drugs here and you bring the drugs there.
And if people,
people started fucking with the business much like bitcoin and shit,
they just started trying to fuck with it.
And you know,
by the way you deal with a lot of criminals are going to do some criminal shit.
They're going to try to put it over on you.
Now,
one of the things that Silk Road did was it was like a craigslist for like
hitman and shit,
so he was like,
okay,
you're on my,
my Silk Road.
I'm going to,
you know,
this guy's bad for soak roadies dealing shitty heroin or he's being bad or he's
saying some shit,
so he just would have them killed,
allegedly allegedly would have them kill because he was trying to maintain the
sort of quality of his product.
So there was assassinations,
hit man arms dealing,
drug dealing all on this sort of dark web shit that was going on.
Then they caught the earthquake,
an earthquake,
what are you doing?
Is that like an effect?
I was going to switch cameras,
but then it was,
oh just,
I'm like,
what the fuck is this an effect?
This is a new artistic,
but what I find interesting about this is it's just an example of this whole
second economy,
the gray economy,
the black economy,
black market that some people have estimated is up to a quarter to a half of
what the global economy is.
Because if you put in all the drugs that are dealt in the world,
all the arms that are dealt in the world,
right?
All the secondary quote Unquote Gurus,
gray electronics,
the seconds,
the,
the stolen IP coming out of China,
all of that stuff.
Because if you go to India,
everything is at 20 $20 pirated smartphone,
right?
Like hundreds of millions of these fucking things.
I mean,
so all of this gray economies being run somehow and there's bitcoin and there's
Silk Road and there's all these different crazy fucking things that are out
there running this shit.
And that's why I was,
I was talking,
I agree with you.
I agree with what you're saying because all money is now,
it's just data.
It's just,
it's,
this bank has this many credits and that bank has that and we swapped them up.
It's not based on the gold standard.
It's not based on anything.
And so,
you know,
bitcoin or virtual currencies are interesting,
but you know,
they can be hacked as,
as,
as we just saw in Japan.
But also,
you know,
what can you,
what can you actually buy and sell with them?
Because what they're doing is they're actually using the old drug dealers or
slash terrorists,
um,
system,
which is,
okay,
I've got some corn in Tunisia and you've got some flax in Pakistan.
And those would just be wiped out in somebody.
Then in Afghanistan we'll get a case of a AK 47,
and that's what bitcoin and that's what Silk Road.
And that's what a lot of these things ended up doing.
AndW didn't one guy wind up going to jail because he gave bitcoins or he,
he,
he sold bitcoins to someone who wound up using those bitcoins to buy drugs.
We'll see.
This is the deal.
And that,
that's a very good point because they didn't even buy the drugs because after it
nine 11,
what happened was the government said,
by the way,
they pretty much know everything's going.
So they went into mutual funds.
They went into Switzerland,
they,
I have a house in Costa Rica and there was this development fund and Costa Rica
was,
uh,
you know,
a lot of foreigners go down there and retire there and they were investing in
the,
in the,
in the country.
But because one guy in the fund had ties to a drug cartel,
everybody,
they just took all the money.
It was like two and a half billion dollars.
Just took the drug laundering fund.
So we're going to take all the mice,
all these gringos,
lost all their retirement funds.
And by the way,
what's interesting about who took that money?
The American government.
Sure.
After nine 11 and by they way,
they took trillions of dollars doing this off the bat.
It's not on the books,
it's not on the books because they just took it in and wow,
there you go.
They're allowed to do with it.
Whatever they want to do.
Right.
After nine,
they went around everywhere
and they use the world sympathy to say,
okay,
now we're going to,
now we're going to take this money.
We know it's drug laundering.
We know this is this,
we know this is this,
we're going to take it all.
And they just took it off.
Wow.
And they,
how hilarious is that?
They use terrorism.
They were used mass murder as a pretense of stealing drug dealers money and
everybody else is around.
Like if I invested in this thing
and then some dude I never even met in message one time dealt drugs,
then they take get to take my money to,
do you know what,
that there's a quote about
capitalizing on,
uh,
any sort of a,
a moment that it's negative moment.
Well,
any,
any negative moment that it becomes even more negative,
you know,
capitalize on it.
But that's the idea behind a,
almost every government,
they don't look at negative moments and any sort of a mass casualty event,
they don't look at it as just a tragedy.
They also look at it as an opportunity to,
we use that tragedy to further whatever ideas they have.
Real politic zero sum game politics.
There is a winner and there is a loser and I'm going to be the winner.
I think what we're dealing with right now is the adolescence of the emergence of
instant technology,
the emergence of Internet information.
And right now it's only a few people that have their greasy pause on this kind
of shit.
And when Edward Snowden comes out with all this data,
when Wiki leaks comes out with all this data,
and then everybody's like,
wait,
what?
This is what I've been calling this generation.
The wait what generation?
Because I feel like that's what's going on.
I feel like a lot of us are in the middle of going,
wait,
what?
What?
I like,
what I like about it is that it's proof.
You sit there and you say,
oh,
it's not true.
Here it is.
Here's the NSA,
here's the FBI,
here's the CIA.
These are the files.
This is what it says.
Here's the proof.
Yeah.
The,
and it is,
I mean,
people used to call Alex Jones a fucking complete crazy person.
And it's weird when a ranting lunatic is right 90% of the time.
That's scary,
you know?
I mean,
that's when it gets scary.
He's right about so much shit.
So much of what he called in the nineties by the way,
when I met him,
I met him in [inaudible] 98 and he was calling all this shit.
He was saying they are going to be monitoring your emails.
I'm like,
fuck you,
my email.
You know where I'm going to go to do comedy wanting to get 100% true.
Yeah.
I mean,
what we're dealing with right now is a few people that have this power,
and I think it's going to come down to a point in time where as this technology
increases,
if you just looked at it,
don't look at it in the context of culture.
Don't look in the context of what we're accustomed to as far as our expectations
and privacy,
but instead look at it as it is.
It's a wave that's moving in a certain direction.
Well,
where's it going?
What's it?
What's it doing?
It's moving in the direction.
What's the direction?
Well,
the direction is information being passed freely.
What's money information?
What's going to happen?
It's going to hit a roadblock and the roadblock is people want to keep a hold
their money.
They want to control the money,
there's going to be no control of the money.
The whole thing is about access.
The whole thing is about access to this information.
And as this whole thing grows and expands and becomes more powerful and more
prevalent and more pervasive,
it's gonna reach a bottleneck.
And I think that bottleneck is money.
I really do.
Well,
I've got another question.
Re Money [inaudible] 2008,
right?
Recession.
What,
what,
what sparks out of that is riots in Europe,
Arab spring,
all across the Middle East,
riots and Southeast Asia,
riots in South America,
rights around the world by Gen y because they completely disenfranchised.
No future.
You take someone's future away,
what they're gonna do,
they're gonna smash it up.
Why wouldn't they?
That's what revolution has been historically.
Okay.
So now,
you know,
China's fucked.
They're slowing down and they're in real trouble.
India's rupee is collapsing.
Uh,
you know,
we're,
it's,
it's not a question of if,
it's a question of when,
what happens when you have another economic downturn and the people who have
been sort of treading water and just are starting to see some like go down
again.
What happens then on an economic level when you have these young people who have
been fucked for the past eight years,
say,
okay,
fuck,
I'm going to have to tighten my belt for another eight.
I don't know what the economy is.
I don't understand it.
You know,
when,
when you talk about one house being worth $5 million in one house be worth in
Detroit,
$500 and this is a valuable place to live and this is,
and this guy gets paid $100,000 for the same job that this woman gets paid
$30,000 for.
And they both worked the same amount of hours and a certain point in time was
like,
what is our economy?
It's a construct.
Well,
what,
what are we selling?
What are we buying and where?
Where's it all coming from?
Who you made it up,
right?
But here's the question.
If it worked in 2006,
okay,
if two in 2006,
if everything was rosy and people are buying houses and everything was great,
you'd buy a house,
he'd sell it a year lady and make 50 grand.
What,
what is that?
What?
What's different now?
Someone will,
you know,
you talked to people that are economic experts and they give you some sort of an
explanation of how people extracted money from the system.
How the banks,
we banked on the fact that the loans they were giving and then somehow than they
made money.
Well,
what does that mean?
What does it mean?
Like we're the same people are working,
there's a same amount of stuff.
There's the same amount of cars cause the same amount of buildings,
there's the same,
roughly the same amount of furniture.
What the fuck is going on?
Then all of a sudden everything's terrible and no one could get a job.
I love obviously be very simple.
I got it.
Yeah.
What I love about it is,
uh,
recently,
somebody came up as very,
it's a very good idea by the way,
to try to explain economic disparity.
And there was a time when the aristocrats who were,
you know,
been knighted by God and they owned everything and everybody else worked for
them.
That's how it worked.
They,
the,
they could fuck the,
the first port daughters before they got married,
they could do whatever they want.
They were the law.
They collected the taxes.
It was a mafia system.
It was,
we collect the tax
here and pay up to the king over there.
What's interesting is they just did a thing on,
uh,
there's more economic disparity today.
Then during the Downton Abbey era of the aristocracy owned everything and
everybody else was like,
you know,
screwed.
Which is when the,
the,
you know,
Sylvia Revolution started and the big socialist wave around the world because
the aristocrats own everything and there's more economic disparity today than
there was then.
Is it because the people that like the people that know how to fuck with money,
the 1% yes.
Just have accumulated insane,
impossible to imagine.
Well,
the aristocrats were given their God given,
right?
We own the land because at the time it was horizontal production is I have to
make more carrots,
you know?
And so the only way of getting more carrots was to have more land.
So I took over your land.
That's why there was constant warfare and then it went to vertical production,
which is technology.
So now whoever owns the sort of technological means can sort of,
you know,
write their own ticket.
So you're exactly right.
So the 1% now know how to game the system,
you know better than,
than,
than most.
To put it into perspective,
what were we were talking about earlier when I was saying that I don't
understand the economy.
I mean I understand competition.
I understand if one person is better at their job,
they should make more than another person who's better at their job.
But when you look at big money,
crazy money,
where's it coming from?
A lot of times,
who is,
whose,
whose capitalizing on it?
The people that work with big money bankers.
Like,
what are they doing exactly?
They're not digging holes that mean what the fuck are they doing where they have
$1 trillion or whatever the fuck.
Uh,
you know,
a Lehman Brothers guy has,
has one of those giant hundred acre estates on the Hamptons.
Where are they and what do they,
where are they make their money?
And this is very,
it's just a,
again,
I'm going to put it into gambling terms cause I'm a gambler.
If you could go to Vegas,
right?
And you could say,
okay,
I'm going to bet $1 billion or $1 trillion,
but let's say a billion,
let's say $1 million.
So we got on,
I got to put $1 million on black.
Well,
I lost.
Okay,
I'm going to write that off.
So I didn't really,
there's not going to put $1 billion on black.
I lost again.
Okay,
I'm going to write that off.
I put a billion,
uh Oh,
I won.
I get to keep that money.
Yeah,
I play that every day.
I would play that game every fucking day of the Goddamn we.
But guess what?
They don't,
or you do that game in Vegas,
but they let you do that game on Wall Street.
It's unbelievable.
It's so hard to wrap your head around when you really try to think about the
amount of money being exchanged.
And then the fast mind boggling,
it's fine.
But the fact that this argument was thrown about that they're too big to fail
and then,
you know,
the government comes in and bails them out and set taxpayers,
government,
the government doesn't have any money and they steal it from the tax payer
government gets its money from taxpayers.
And that's what,
you know,
I just did this thing,
uh,
on,
on Afghanistan.
But that's the tip of the iceberg is how much money
the government throws away.
And by the way,
I pay a ship of fucking tax.
So when I see that,
I'm like,
oh,
Whoa,
my tax just went down the fucking toilet.
Runaway.
In what way?
What do you mean?
Well,
so for example,
the piece I did in Afghanistan is we've spent $100 billion,
uh,
and reconstruction there.
And the majority of it,
if not all of it,
has just been flushed down the toilet.
For example,
$1 billion were spent on helicopters that don't fly,
you know,
billions of dollars are spent on,
on,
um,
uh,
culvert denial system.
It's a long story,
but basically to try to stop by eds from being put into cover,
they were never built.
We're paying money directly into the Taliban sans.
We build a power plants that are never used because they're inefficient and too
expensive because they use diesel and diesel can't,
you can't power power plants with diesel.
And by the way,
guests who collects the,
uh,
the fees are the Taliban because of the places where we go into collect,
the fees were too dangerous to actually go into.
So we're just throwing hundreds of billions of dollars down the toilet.
That's just Afghanistan.
Not to mention the rack,
not to mention by the way,
dod,
not to mention here in America,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So you sit there and you say,
we're paying all this money in,
tax taxes are going up,
up,
up.
And,
and where the fuck is the money going?
The money's going into the fucking toilet.
Many cases.
And you sit there and you say,
that's not fucking good,
man.
That's not good.
It's,
it's a sort of a symptom of what happens when money's there.
When mine is there and it's legal to extract it,
all of a sudden a bunch of people start going,
wow.
I think,
I think unless we question it's our money.
So this is the whole basis of democracy.
It's our government and it's our money.
And what's happening now is the government is acting with impunity with no,
and like you said,
I'm like,
what about climate change?
What about war?
What about all the shit?
And you're like,
well,
people feel disenfranchised.
They can't do anything about it.
Hey B,
it's their money that people are spending and,
and,
and we're going,
well,
fuck,
they shouldn't be spending 70,
$80,000 hammers.
That's not fucking cool.
Well,
the basis of democracies,
you don't do that.
The basis of democracy,
you can't do that.
But what's happening now,
and this is what I find it another problem in our modern age is,
okay,
this is a fucking huge problem yet we can we,
we feel we can't do anything about it.
And,
and I've said this before and now I'm into my drink.
So I'm going to say it again,
is that's why these podcasts are important.
That's why media is important.
That's why journalism is important.
Look,
you started out in a different way.
You came at this from a different way.
I came at this from a different way.
The reason why we're doing this now is because we're frustrated and we're
saying,
look,
I don't want to talk about,
you know,
shoes fucking every day of the week.
You don't want to just do stand up or,
or,
or your MMA ship,
both of which are,
but you want to do something only fuck dudes,
I'm gonna fucking talk about shit because this shit is important.
The reason why we have to do that is because we can't be complacent.
We can't just sit there and say,
you know what?
Fuck is too much money or there's too much because they are taking money to do
bad things with it.
They are taking our fucking freedoms and and and spying on us with the NSA and
it's guys like you and guys like me and guys like by the way everybody out there
in the fucking death squad and rap band and all these mother fuckers and we have
to be the ones to get out there on a grassroots moon and say fuck you,
stop fucking tapping my phone.
Stop taking my money to fucking throw down into the Taliban tans and Afghanistan
stopped this shit because unless we do then there's going to be no more
democracy in America.
I think you're certainly right in some ways and I think also what's going on is
this idea of us versus them.
It's completely ridiculous and I think people that are in positions of power are
going to be forced to realize this.
You are us.
Yeah.
All of you people that are congressmen,
all you people that are senators,
all you people that are mayors,
all you people that are cops,
you are us.
There is no us and them.
Correct.
Especially when you're dealing with those sort of positions,
the positions of political power,
positions of authority that you are us.
You're not even profiting off of this.
You,
if you want to put yourself into a position where you sell your soul to profit
off it,
then you're not us.
But for right now,
anybody jockeying into any,
any sort of a political position,
understand that it doesn't have to be this way.
Understand that you are us and there you are.
People who have wives and children and families and jobs and dogs.
We're all human.
And I believe that we can somehow or another construct an economy that's based
on ethics and morals.
I really do.
I don't think there's anything that says that everybody has to be greedy.
I don't think there's anything that says that people have to capitalize and
every single fucking loophole and fuck everybody over along the way.
And I think one of the reasons why they've been away are allowed to do this or
able to do this for so long is because of the lack of access to information.
I think they were able to secret secretly hide so much shitty,
wrong doing in the past and that it became policy.
It became habit.
It became what you were taught when you were young,
when you joined a company,
Hey,
this is how we do it and you know,
you want to fucking play golf with us and drive a Ferrari.
All right,
I'm in.
And next thing you know,
you're compromise just sort of like Leonardo Dicaprio's character was
compromised and the wolf of Wall Street,
I don't know if that's how it actually happened in real life,
but he started in with good ideas and it was invested into a completely corrupt
system and then became a part of it and became a part of the corruption that is
essentially most likely what happens in every form of government.
Essentially.
There's good people that eventually join this thing and then realize,
oh,
this is a completely compromised movement.
There's no way to fix it.
I'll just be one of those guys.
And they'll drink every night and I take Xanax.
I think it's going to have system.
I think it has to you.
I agree.
But I also think it's going to stop because you're not going to be able to just
write it off.
It's dark.
It's going to be everyone.
The same reason why you can spy on people in Camden,
New Jersey,
that is the echo of a,
a future event that's going to happen that's going to remove all privacy and it
is inevitable,
but I'm going to say on a personal level,
you've done well.
I've done well.
We're two guys sorta sitting at the the nice end of the spectrum saying,
hey,
it's got to fucking change.
If you and I are saying it's got to change and we're at the winning end of the
fucking scratch and win,
then guess what?
Shit is fucked up.
Well,
there's no,
I agree that you and I have,
we're both comfortable.
We don't have to worry about feeding ourselves or housing our families,
but what happens at a certain point in time when you,
you make enough money that you don't have to worry about your bills,
you at least I start contemplating what is important.
Correct.
Important.
Right?
What's important,
this is so corny,
but what's important is love.
What's important is friendship.
What's important is,
you know,
it's nice to walk down the street and say hi to your neighbor.
If your neighbor is happy,
if your neighbor is being held at fucking point and a dragging them in the
house,
it's not so fun to say hi to your neighbor.
Oh,
hi neighbor,
you have a gun to your head.
Oh,
sorry.
What did you do wrong?
Yeah,
I'm over here.
You know?
Sorry,
I'm having a great time to go watch TV.
I didn't do anything wrong.
The gamestops beyond.
It's only fun if everybody's having fun.
That's what community's all about.
It's one of the reasons why human beings evolved into the point where we're at
right now to the point where we have cities and in cultures,
and I mean we,
we had to make it at least safe enough that everybody could with it
grew up in a village mentality.
We all grew up in villages and everybody hung out together,
went to the pub together and did all this to shit together.
That's how we operate at our best.
Exactly.
And then we sort of separated into this sort of suburban thing,
but now it's like you're exactly right.
It's this community,
we're part of this community.
What I find interesting and every time I do this podcast,
I am always blown away by it is there's so many people out there that think
exactly the same way and we all sort of believe the same things and think the
same things and we're all interested in the same things or pissed off about the
same things yet.
Like that's millions and millions of literally millions of fucking people.
And yet it's,
there's this sort of frustration as to what the fuck you do with that.
Yes.
What does,
there's never been anything to do before you had to wait for representatives to
do you justice.
You had to vote for people that were going to disappoint you.
You had to get yourself to the polls and hope that all your bitching and moaning
at work and all year,
you know,
reading the Wall Street Journal and the New York Times somehow in her,
that made a difference.
And most of the time it didn't.
It didn't because there was,
there was walls,
there was wall.
What's the wall though?
Not there anymore.
The walls,
the distribution of information.
Same thing we're talking about with money.
Podcast is essentially just a distribution of information device that's never
been available before.
Vice is a distribution of information device that's never been available before.
There was never some crazy Fox from Canada that we're going to the Congo looking
for dinosaurs and talking to cannibals and Liberia.
That shit never happened,
man.
The most radical shit you had was John Stossel asking a pro wrestler whether or
not I was really getting smacked in the head.
Oh my God.
He hit him in the head.
That was like radical journalism.
Uh,
you know,
on television,
on mainstream television just a few decades ago.
I mean,
there,
that was a hard hitting journalist.
You know,
there,
there wasn't anybody,
you know,
we're going to go to Waco and watch from the background as the government takes
Sherman tanks and rolls over houses.
But what's really going on there with the,
no one's going in.
No one's fucking playing guitar with David Koresh and finding out what the fuck
is actually happening.
You guys would,
David Choe would be sitting right next to David Koresh is the burnt that fucking
building down.
You know,
he'd be wearing as best as underwear,
jumping off the fucking roof with a camera,
you know,
running to you and you would upload it online.
True,
true,
true.
It's a different world.
Is this guy like you is not supposed to be in the position that you're in?
You're right.
It's true.
A guy like me,
it's not supposed to be in a position I'm in.
Correct.
I'm easily marginalized.
I marginalize myself at every point in time I can.
I want everybody to know that I'm a,
I'm a fucking Schmoe.
The falls,
you have a huge grassroots uprising at your back,
pushing you is fucking amazing.
Which is why I love coming here.
Well,
they just know that I'm a lightening Rod.
That's all it is.
It's a,
I'm a,
I'm exactly
like you have to give a shit.
You don't give a shit to say what you want to say.
You don't give a shit
the head.
Too many times do the sun wrong with me.
I've got issues for sure.
I mean I'm impulsive.
I don't make smart choices.
Come on.
What I love about you is you don't give a fuck.
You're going to tell the truth.
You're going to say whatever it is.
I wish I could back you up on this,
but the problem is I can't remember a time where ever gave a fuck.
I don't really think it was a conscious decision that's good.
Black of raising.
I was never raised.
I was raised by wolves.
I was thrown to the wild.
I think really that's what it is.
I never developed a sense of decor.
I never developed a real sense of how you're supposed to behave and act and my
parents were always fucking busy and the people I hung out with were derelicts
and then fighters.
It was all just chaos from the time I was a young boy,
there was never anything that made any sense to me,
so I never figured out how to integrate.
I was never integrated into any system.
Right.
So it's almost like I was designed for this.
Like there's like,
like there's only one way to make someone who actually had Ronnie who was so
stupid.
They'll say anyone that's ironic.
Talk
about that is that you integrate so well cause you're funny and people like
you because you're funny.
You know more about MMA than anyone I've ever met in my life,
which is the fast growing sport in the world.
You're like the most politically astute dude around it.
You know more about,
you know,
more about more shit than anyone I've ever met.
So you're saying I don't fit it.
You probably fit in better than anyone I've ever seen.
Well it is the system that's broken.
It's not correct.
What I have been very fortunate is that I grew up like this in a time or you can
access enormous amounts of information and during the last 20 years because of
this access to enormous amount of information,
no enormous amounts,
my change,
my perspective on the world has changed radically.
Yeah.
My view has broadened its in an insane way that's impossible to describe.
But I think that I represent one,
I just,
I represent one portal that all,
almost everyone who's a part of the system,
whether they grew up in a way where they were forced to sort of integrate,
and they did things that I did do because they had a better upbringing and
whatever it was,
they also see it.
But my position,
my job is the lightening Rod.
I'm,
I'm the,
I'm the guy who's got a door open.
I'm like,
come on,
let's go.
This is a fucking a door.
I mean,
that's all it is.
It's just,
and what you guys are doing is way crazy,
but I'm doing,
what I'm doing is talking about what you guys are doing.
You're off going to fucking North Korea and having lunch with these fucking
psychopaths and you know,
you're going to visit slave camps where they,
they,
uh,
they think they're in North Korea,
but they're actually in Russia when it was [inaudible].
They are rushing.
Yeah.
They think they're North Korea,
but they're actually in Russia.
Yeah.
They're in a slave concentration camps in North Korea,
but they're actually in Russia doing slave labor.
Yeah.
See you're going to all these places like the North Pole.
Well,
you're not going to see me there,
but I'll,
I'm the lightning rod.
I'll stay right here.
All right.
Lights on.
Anytime you want to come by.
We'll fucking,
we'll hit the switch and we'll broadcast as vice done.
Anything about the cove or anything about the dolphins
situation up in Japan?
Yeah,
I noticed your hat there.
Yeah.
Uh,
we have actually,
and,
and uh,
we're doing a lot more on not just to cove,
which is a tiny problem.
It's actually a global problem in the fact that we've over fished.
Everything says no more fish left.
And so now what we're doing is just,
you know,
completely the only,
the only fishermen left are the sort of,
you know,
the,
the bad ones who were like perceiving and taking the whole,
almost like pirates.
Exactly.
They take the whole,
uh,
um,
tuna pod and they,
they,
they put a thing around,
they moved the whole pod in one go and the dolphins and everything that,
that haunted tuna and sharks,
everything,
they all get killed.
They just would kill the fuck out of everything.
Like we're really good at it.
Japanese are ruthless when it comes to that shit.
Quite frankly,
we're all routes.
We're all ruthless withdrawal,
rootless.
He knows every single nation that fishes.
So I'm from Canada originally and the,
there was a time when the ships,
the joke was the f the ships couldn't get through the grand banks,
uh,
off the new Brunswick because the,
there were so many fish.
There's no fish left anymore.
And by the way,
your,
your people who deny everything,
when I say they're like,
the seals ate all the fuck.
If he had a look and see what we should have the seal hunt,
it wasn't the Portuguese,
the Japanese,
the Canadians,
the Americans who fucking perceived it for fucking 50 years and ate all the God
damn fish and threw everything else out.
No,
it wasn't that.
It was the fucking seals.
Anyway,
we have destroyed the,
the fish stocks.
There's no more fucking fish.
We were like,
like now everything has to be farmed,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
There's no more fish in the grand banks.
It was the biggest fish stocks in the fucking world.
Why?
Because we used to fish,
you know,
we used to fish a certain way.
Then we just said,
fucking take all the fish,
take everything,
take it up.
Just scoop the fucking whole fucking side of the ocean and we'll just take it.
Is it because of just an economic need?
Economical needs,
Amish.
There's more people.
If you,
if you go to any store,
this is an interesting thing that I,
you go to any store in the world,
any story.
You can be in Congo,
you can be in Australia,
you can be in Vietnam,
Myanmar,
you can be here in America.
You know what they're going to have on the,
on the,
on the shelf of any shitty Bodega and the fucking world.
Tuna,
canned tuna fish.
So it's like a staple.
And when you realize the,
the stakes that we're talking now,
like I was doing this a piece on fake food in China.
They have fake eggs right now.
What is that?
And I'm like,
you have fake eggs.
So they're making a,
a fake soya construct for the shell and a fake chemical thing for the thing and
the Yolk.
I'm like,
how much is the fucking egg costs?
Like an egg is free.
You get a chicken,
fucking eggs come out.
How much does it take to make a chemical egg?
You know,
there's must cost a lot more than the actual egg itself.
It doesn't make any sense.
There's no eggs in China,
you know,
there's no milk in China,
so they're just buying all the dairies and France,
it was a big article today.
They need food.
So they're making fake food.
But you sit there and you say,
okay tuna,
it's on every,
every single country in the world.
It has to,
well,
there's no more tuna.
We ate it all cause everybody eats tuna.
When you start saying that,
everybody has to have that one thing because you're like,
all these,
the biggest corporations in the world,
what do they sell?
Light Bulbs,
Tampons,
you know,
toothbrushes,
shit that everybody needs.
I,
every single person in the world needs a fucking toothbrush or light bulbs.
So they make billions of our tuna,
right?
There's no more tuna.
So what the fuck did they do?
They say,
well,
just take everything.
Take the kids,
take the eggs,
take the fucking,
you know,
the adults take the,
the breeding females,
take everybody,
chop it up,
put it in the fucking tuna can.
Wow.
And that's the problem is food.
Where,
and by the way,
this is happening now with beef,
I know you're into grassfed beef.
Beef now is a huge problem.
Prices skyrocketing.
Why?
Because now everybody wants beef.
There's people have been born boxes and so now beef prices are going through the
roof.
They're also getting sneaky with their grass fed.
A hundred percent,
hundred percent grass fed.
You can go to whole foods.
They have this new thing that they're doing,
what they call it,
pasture raised.
Have you seen that?
Look,
beef is fucked.
Fishes.
Fuck.
Protein in general is fucked because it's expensive.
It's expensive to fucking rear and,
and,
and make happen.
But fish by the way,
is the scariest because we've over fished to the point where there are like,
unless it's farmed,
we're fucked.
And it doesn't seem like there's any light at the end of the tunnel.
Well,
this is the thing,
and I keep saying this when I come on the show is where all the adults like,
okay,
isn't it?
Like if there's,
if the option is we can stop eating so much fish for a little bit and then have
fish forever or we can just keep on eating all the fucking fish and then never
have fish forever ever again.
Wouldn't it be the same decision to say let's eat a little bit less fish so we
can all have fish where no,
we're actually doing the opposite and saying,
well no one actually has the the cause.
If we don't do it,
then the Japanese will do it and if the Japanese are doing it,
then we have to do it.
So we're all going to just
eat all the food.
Well,
you don't hear about that story because it's important to talk about Miley Cyrus
twerking.
Very important.
We don't have time for your torn tuna nonsense.
When young Miley,
she was Hannah Montana and now she's twerking.
Yeah.
It's disturbing that you don't hear more of it.
And I think that's an issue with most people that follow the mainstream media.
Most people that work a nine to five plus,
you know,
commuting time,
they simply do not have time.
10 it's hard.
It's very hard.
Life is hard.
Yeah.
And you don't want to come home and have a couple of old motherfuckers like us.
Guess what?
All the fishes gone.
You fucking dirty bastard.
Stop eating your fucking tuna fish sandwich.
You don't want to be on the fucking sub.
Look,
it's,
it's hard.
It's difficult.
But the problem is is the bill is not only in the mail,
it's been fucking deliver.
We did.
We did a lot of bad things for a long time and now the bill has been delivered
and we're sitting here going,
there's no more fish.
Boys.
Sorry.
Like,
and by the way,
guess what?
We're not going to wake up.
This is the sad thing about humans.
We're not going to wake up until you walk into the quickie mart or the seven
level,
whatever the fuck it is,
and there's no more tune on the shelves.
You Go,
what happened to the fucking tune,
Huh?
Yeah,
we ate it at all yet.
That's a weird thing about us,
isn't it?
That we,
we,
we have that issue.
We don't recognize things until it's like,
it's like they say about addicts that addicts have to hit rock fucking bottom
before they'll stop doing drugs.
Like they have to have overdoses where they're almost dead.
Change addicts would humans.
Yeah.
Well it's,
well,
that's what I'm saying.
I mean,
I think it's,
it's,
it's a similar thing that we do when we get into patterns like guys who are
gambling addicts.
You ever met a gambling addict?
Well,
in the unit,
you're fine.
Listen,
No,
he's fine to there.
But you're talking about too wealthy guys,
this scary gambling addicts of the guys who are broke who have to fucking bet.
I knew this guy's name was white plains,
Charlie white plains,
Joe White Plains.
Charlie might've weighed 50 pounds.
He used to hang out at the pool hall that I used to go to and he was a real good
pool player.
But he's an old man who was a gambling junkie,
used to steal candy bars and the Pool Hall and you see him fucking sneaky.
I mean he just needed some form nutrition.
All White Plains Charlie would do all day was gamble in one way or another.
He lived in a boarding house.
He like had a room somewhere or a bed or somewhere and he was probably,
when I met him,
probably deep in his sixties white plains,
Charlie's to go to the fucking horse races every day and he would come to the
pool hall after you went to the horse races and like this mother Fucker,
I bet this horse,
this fucking,
I'm like,
come on your cock sucker.
It always,
same story,
always losing.
And if he did have some money,
you could tell because he was all squirrely and he could see him and everybody
knew and then he would wind up gambling and losing that money.
But these poor fucks,
man,
they,
they could never just get a job,
get their shit together.
They were addicted to these weird thrills and they would hit rock bottom and
just scraped together enough money.
And then they decided somewhere along the line,
Charlie decided to just live at rock bottom.
Rock bottom was where he was.
He always smelled.
He would take cigarettes out of ash trays and light them up again.
And you know,
he's essentially not homeless,
but might've well been homeless,
was always broke,
always bumming money,
always asking someone to stay,
come,
this motherfucker can't beat me.
I'm gonna play this motherfucker.
I'm going to rob him.
You're gonna,
we're gonna make it a lot of money.
Come on man.
Back then,
back me up on it.
It was,
and he was just addicted to it and he,
he would crash and just keep going.
And there's a lot of people like that when it comes to anything.
And I think that's a human characteristics,
this denial and this,
this ability to rationalize the position that you're in.
And I think as a species we do that,
well,
I forget,
I'm going to misquote this,
I'm going to butcher it,
but there's a definition of insanity,
which is we go to bed every night with the same thing facing us and the same
conditions facing us the next day and we wake up thinking it's going to be
different.
Yeah,
that's the,
the,
the simplified version is the definition of insanity is doing the exact same
thing and expecting a different result.
Correct.
Which is basically the definition of humanity and the definition of history.
Well,
it's also one of the reasons why we're such bad motherfuckers that we're able to
like put things aside and trudge ahead
the definition of,
of religion because they're like,
yeah,
it's shitty again today,
but guess what?
When you're dead,
it's going to be awesome.
Jesus will be there.
Re pour that in other,
you had another bad day.
It's sucked again and you worked real hard.
But when you're dead
Kimanzi Fred Phelps is dead.
You know that the Westboro Baptist Church guy died.
You imagine the day,
if Jesus is real,
the day that that guy meets Jesus and Jesus is like,
that's not what I meant.
Right.
That's all my,
you know what I love about it is like I go,
I travel a lot to hardcore Islamic countries and they were like,
yeah,
you know you're going to jihad and and suicide bombers and you're going to go to
paradise.
You're going to have versions,
and you're like,
yeah,
it's fucking crazy.
And you'd come back to American,
like those motherfucking Taliban and alcaide Qaeda,
they're crazy motherfuckers.
They believe they're going to fucking die and she had to go to heaven.
What do you guys believe?
We believe Jewish zombies.
The walk on water,
that I get to work everyday and have a bad life every,
every,
every day of my life and then I'm going to fucking die and go to heaven.
Yeah,
well we don't believe in virgins,
so it's less,
it's less for,
the promise is get 70 virgins,
but I live on a cloud and eat Velveeta cheese.
Our Shit is more reasonable and updated.
Their shit is very ancient,
like they're dealing with it.
I believe that what's going on in the Middle East is that the Middle East,
I've said this before,
is the cradle of civilization.
That's where Mesopotamia was.
Babylon.
That's where Sumir was.
Everyone.
I think Turkey that mean the oldest known civilization that's built complex
structures is in go Beckley Tapi in Turkey.
This new thing that they found over the last decade,
incredible structures.
The people that are still there,
I think are the townies of the world.
That's what I think it's like,
it's like when you go back to where you grew up and all those assholes that stay
there just so backwards and outdated.
I go to where I grew up and I see my friends,
it's still in the same town like,
fuck man.
Like you guys gotta get Outta here fucking fired.
He's wanting to get fucking married.
They got to eat.
You're a tennis shoe.
Newton Newton,
Massachusetts,
Newton upper falls.
Um,
and that's actually a great place to live.
And I'm just talking shit.
But what I'm talking about is that there are certain people that live in an area
and that area has an ideology that's very rigid.
And they never get out of it.
Yeah.
These,
this because they,
their ideology was created 15,000 years ago.
They have the echoes of that retarded civilization,
but thought the world was flat
worship goats.
The interesting thing about Islam though is it was created as much as you say,
as a,
uh,
it was basically a,
remember by the way,
watch a jihad be a announced we're flat wall.
I mean it was created because went to Jay and said,
oh this,
there's this new Christian thing going on.
So that was this monotheistic thing saying,
oh,
there's this new one,
God religion.
I'm going to take that on.
So Judaism actually in the Koran it says people are the book.
There's the Jews and the Christians and the Muslims,
and they're all the same because of the monotheistic and you say,
oh,
okay,
well that's,
that's interesting people of the book,
you know,
we're all in it together.
Why the fuck have you been a,
you know,
fighting us the whole time?
Well,
we have different versions of heaven.
how about the Islamic people themselves have to different sects of Islam,
the shadow each other to the death,
which is a lot more than two but two big ones.
The big one.
And I ran as Sunni and Shia that we didn't know about it and I racked when when
people started blowing each other up in Iraq and we found out that it was
Islamic people attacking rival Islamic sex.
We were like,
wait a minute,
how crazy are these fucking people?
This is a civil war amongst both bullshit.
Exactly.
What I was trying to get to is Judaism,
Christianity,
Islam are basically the same religion they started yeah.
Rooted.
Exactly.
There you go.
Yeah.
And so and so there people,
the book,
etc. Etc.
And you sit there and saying,
your definition of having this different than my debt or your definition of this
is different.
Or Jesus was a prophet,
but Mohammed was a real prophet and there and you say,
okay,
because of all that we're going to kill the fuck out of each other for a long
fucking time.
And at that point you're like,
well this is just fucking stew.
Well,
it's all fucking stupid because Saugus we look at them and say,
Oh,
you're going to get 70 virgins because you blew yourself up with the suicide,
but Stephanie to you're fucking ridiculous.
However,
I'm going to go to heaven and live on a cloud with my fucking savior.
Jesus.
How,
how is that any fucking diff?
It's just as ridiculous.
But the,
the,
you know the term 72 virgins apparently.
What they mean when they say 72,
seven 72 is like,
uh,
like you would say a fucking kazillion.
Yeah.
You know,
like you would get 72.
It's just,
there's one thing I'm saying,
it was actually meant 70 to raise on this fun raisins.
Look,
the fact of the matter is that we,
yeah,
it was raised in and that's not,
I'm not that up.
Google it.
Fucking skimpy little walk.
I want you to fucking back me up on the raisins.
There was only 72 I'd be pissed.
Yeah,
exactly.
All that bit,
that old school.
But yeah,
the,
uh,
the idea that 72 raisins is a lot of raisins.
It's just as insulting as 72 virgins in heaven.
But what's interesting is is is those religions were created.
Muslim martyrs get 72 raises instead of versions.
Oh God.
Is that up there?
Hey,
well,
we believe you're a good,
very good,
right?
That's Google's good.
Very good.
Read books.
The kid didn't go out,
get an encyclopedia,
ran outside with his library card.
I just typed
in a future.
You want to be,
there you go.
It's,
it's tying it back to information.
How about the fact
that we have all information in the world,
in the history of the world,
at our fingertips at all times.
It's crazy.
Those other things.
I was gonna say you,
you're exactly right.
When you said the freedom,
the freedom of information and the freedom.
I want to know
it will save us,
but it will change us.
It's going to change everything.
It will change us,
but it will save us.
Look,
if it was just us,
this is something I like to do all the time,
at least to play this game,
but it was only us four.
It was Brian,
Jamie,
you and I,
and we were the only people on earth will be in trouble.
You could read my email.
Who Cares?
I'm emailing you guys.
You know,
I mean,
you could,
you could borrow my food.
There's only four of us.
All the food we have.
We better fucking cherish all the vegetables we have.
We better fucking shares.
If you build a dope house,
um,
and you spend all your time building that dope house,
I mean,
that's your house and all.
I should probably build my own house,
but you know,
we would help each other.
You couldn't really build a house on your own.
We would need each other.
Why wouldn't we?
Right.
We don't necessarily need each other when there's 300 million of us.
And so we have a real issue or 7 billion and we have a real issue,
but we're going to be able to read each other's minds,
ma'am.
That is common and we're going to need real and not purity of thought because
there's nothing wrong with being preferred.
We have to understand that we are perverted all the things.
Yeah.
The things that people enjoy,
sex and talking shit and jerking off and,
and all the nonsense that we enjoy is a part of us.
It's a part of our animal life and we hide a lot of these things because of our
culture.
We hide a lot of these things because of,
you know,
we want to have jobs and we want to have,
there's another bottle of that Jack over there at the bottom.
Oh Shit.
It's another bottle of Jack o Lantern Sodie pop with extra vitamin C.
It's,
it's a,
it's a part of what we are and we're shielding ourselves from our sexuality and
our reality by hiding.
I'm bullshitting all that bullshit and hiding the things that I don't have to do
because I'm a comedian.
The things that Brian is now to do,
we can say crazy shit about what we've done and what we do and drugs and sex and
nonsense.
We can talk about all that because there's no expectations on us to be normal.
We're comedians were,
we're entertainers.
We're crazy people.
But for the average person,
the average person can make with a fucking corporate job,
can't make a youtube video about doing DMT and getting blown by angel.
Yeah.
Talk about this before.
I don't know because my brain is softening,
but targeting when we remembering important shit.
Pardon me,
but I don't know if we talked about this.
It's,
it's,
it's a good thing cause I've just forgotten my question,
but hold on.
What
by what I was saying was that the expectations on a guys like me and Brian,
they don't exist because
we're already silly.
We're were ridiculous people that are,
it's fine if we talk about drugs.
It's fine if we talk about sex.
That was the thing you were saying that,
yeah.
So I don't know if we talked about this before,
but what I find disturbing about political representation is I,
I've done a lot of crazy shit.
I left home when I was like 13 and a half.
I've been a bad boy.
I've been a robber.
I'd be alarmed.
Yeah,
I did a lot of bad things.
I drank a lot,
did a lot of drugs,
did a lot of crazy things.
The fact that our politicians,
and this is one thing that freaked me out of it,
Mitt Romney is here's a guy who didn't ever do anything.
And by the way,
I don't want someone who never did anything.
I want someone who's done everything.
I want someone who reflects me.
So when people say,
you know what chain,
you fucking did drugs and you fuck you fucking did this and you fucking whacked
off and you fucking come sot and Vassar.
I'm like,
yes,
I'm fucking human human.
And by the way,
I would like a politician to say,
yeah,
whacked off from,
came in my fucking back fucking fucking drunk because that's how we are as
normal,
normal.
The fact that we have people who have to be squeaky clean,
which nobody is by the way,
and the fact that you have to be,
to me,
if you're squeaky clean,
you got 20 fucking dead bodies in your,
in your goddamn basement.
Cause I don't trust those motherfuckers who are squeaking or your cries,
never met anyone who squeaky clean.
And nor do I want to worry human.
And what you're saying is exactly right.
You're a fucking freaky business.
I've got freaky business.
Everyone's got freaky business.
Now do I want everyone in the world to know that I've had some freaky business?
Yeah,
probably.
Probably not,
but that's because everybody else can hide their freaky business when there's no
highs.
I don't mind about just some things I do.
There's something,
but what I'm trying to get at is what I,
what I would like from my representation is humanity.
Yeah,
right.
Like we all fuck up.
We all do crazy shit.
We all do some fucking t.
There's,
if I look back,
well,
you fucking admit to everything.
You're like,
oh fuck.
Every fish would be nice if that wiener guy,
if the guy who was running up Andrew Wiener,
he went,
hey,
look,
yes I did.
Yes I did,
but I'm not even him.
The guy running against him.
What if he said,
who cares?
The Guy,
the guy likes to email chicks pictures of his dick.
What are you?
What are you killing?
Fuck,
it's just sex.
What does that have anything to do with the economy?
Well,
his character,
well that's,
that's what they do,
but that's what they do.
Yeah.
That's what they do.
The thing is is is,
is to go after character.
And my thing is when they go after my character,
I go,
yes sir,
I did that,
but put it in the bum bum and I don't feel bad about it.
I'm never done that.
You don't have to be squeaky clean guy
because the expectations aren't on you in that job.
But we have this weird expectation that our politicians are savior or why
politicians had represent us and they don't.
If they don't do ever,
and if they never do anything bad,
then they don't represent us because we all do batch or by the way,
what's bad.
We all do human shit.
Well that's the,
why the fuck aren't our politicians representative of who we are,
which is all doing human shit.
Well,
let's put it into perspective.
This will probably help this discussion.
This whole idea of voting for someone is 200 years old.
Human culture has been around for 10,000 who knows how many thousands of years
voting for someone is really new.
Okay,
so you,
it's a popularity contest instead of a monarchy instead of a dictatorship.
Instead of wish it was a popularity contest.
It's a name recognition contest because you don't know the other fucking names.
That's why he's all this commercials and all this bullshit rigged popularity
contest between two parties that are both represented by the same monopolies and
giant corporations.
But it's still this new thing that they're trying to figure out to us.
It'll go through a whole time and I'm here quoting Smedley Butler wars just to
rack it.
Well that's just because the politicians have really only existed in this form
for a briefs
came of time.
A twitch at the king was born into power.
Exactly.
Now we have to find these fucking guys and they always have,
but that's a user.
Everyone's like,
Oh Hillary Clinton's going to win.
And you're like,
wait,
cause they know her name,
they know the fucking name.
Unless it comes out that Hillary Clinton is stuff and babies backup or pussy and
smothering them.
Well that will come out.
It lasts.
That's less that comes out.
Yeah.
She's got a good show.
I frankly don't think that she'll run and I,
and I'm just going to pause.
I thought you were going to say I was quite fine.
If you don't think she's Tufts babies up,
I'll go.
Listen man,
this is now,
I'm not being literal.
I don't think she'll run because I think,
I think look,
name recognition is there.
Maybe she won't.
I don't know,
but I don't think she'll run because she's old.
She's sick.
Things are coming out now that she's,
she's got health issues.
She is,
she has health issues.
Has A,
what is it,
by the way?
I don't even know if the health issues are true.
They're making a big deal about them.
Well,
she's an older woman.
I mean he's old or older men.
Older women.
They have health issues you sign or sixties right?
How old is she?
She's quiet.
Oh,
well let's look it up.
I don't know.
I don't want to get caught out.
I would say,
I'm going to guess I'd say she's 62 68 oh no,
I got it.
Fucking ass.
That's what he said.
Cause he was like a little trike.
Clinton,
Clintons,
Bill Clinton is very old guy.
She's 66 years old.
Yeah.
So look,
she gets elected at 68 that's when people start dying.
You know what I mean?
That's,
that's,
I mean we used to make fun of Reagan.
Reagan was in his soul.
Was He?
He was in his seventies looking at it.
Is that it?
Was he in the sense,
I believe so.
I believe using a seventies when he was president,
it's all his.
He was a,
because there was that Dennis Miller joke,
he was a bit,
he was a bit Daughtery my grandfather to 72 and we don't let them use a remote
control for the TV.
He has a bit Daughtery now everybody's like,
Oh fuck Reagan.
Reagan.
He was,
oh my God,
can I,
can I ask you another question?
Please do.
The Republicans are all getting in line to say,
I'm a Reagan Republican.
Reagan,
Reagan.
Why isn't the Democratic Party saying lining up saying,
I'm a fucking Clinton centrist fucking took the worst deficits in American
history to the biggest surplus in American history.
Best President fucking serving in,
in,
in the 1900 or 1900.
Uh,
why,
why is he so vilified in this condo?
Lewinski character?
He got a blow job.
So the fact that he was probably the greatest president of the last century,
he goes out the window,
he disparaged the great office of the presidency with his penis.
Do you know what he would do to women?
He would get them alone and pull his penis as opposed to,
as opposed to every other president except for Ronald Reagan because his parents
didn't work.
I wonder,
you know what the standard move was before Viagra.
you know,
like if at a certain point in time you would trust a president because they
didn't get hard ons anymore.
There's a book by Plato,
uh,
called the gorgeous where the main guy and it says,
I only became a good politician when I put all the passions behind me cause he's
like 70,
and he couldn't get his dick hard anymore and he could just be reasonable.
And He,
that was the foundation of democracy was my dick doesn't work anymore so I'll
just start democracies.
I ruin everyone else's lives.
That was,
well it was the founder.
I maybe that was gorgeous.
That was,
that was the first book of uh,
Plato who Socrates never wrote anything,
played a road at all.
He said,
Socrates said this and then that was the foundation of democracy.
It didn't really ruin into Friday.
Medic is back then their,
their ideas of civilization are pretty fucking loose.
He compared to what care act made he,
Socrates and Plato or both fucking little boys left and right.
And it was only,
it was only the,
the dudes,
you know,
there was like,
a hundred people,
slave owners and could vote.
So we're going to base it on their democracy where they went to the Agora and
said Yay or nay.
Do you think the future presidents would definitely like embraced the whole
Clinton thing?
Because look at Obama with doing that video.
What do you mean?
Like the whole Clinton thing,
Obama just did a video is Zach outfit.
It's a lot of heat from,
and that's kind of showing like a really cool prize in,
in my opinion.
What do you mean by getting heat?
I mean a good way or a bad way he's been getting for doing that video.
But what do you mean by heat?
Bad Way,
bad,
bad way.
Saying that the
PR,
there's a lot of people think like Fox News especially,
I think that the president shouldn't be put in that kind of situation even
though that he was like on,
you know,
presidents in the past,
I've done Jay Leno and shit like that.
They just don't remember
exactly.
But I wish,
I wish that Democrats would embrace Clinton as Republicans have embraced Reagan.
Reagan when I grew up was a joke.
He was a daughtering old guy.
Didn't know shit.
Yeah,
me too.
And now they're like,
oh fucking,
I'm better.
I'm more Reagan in your Reagan.
Well,
I grew up as Clinton.
Everyone's like,
get the fuck away from him.
And you're like,
hold on a second.
This guy took the largest deficit in the history of a fucking America and turned
it into largest,
a surplus.
Now they,
they,
they credit Reagan for that.
But it was under Clinton and you know,
this guy was like a consensus politician.
You know,
he worked with the Republicans.
They actually,
the government actually worked,
which it doesn't do now.
Why wouldn't Obama,
why wouldn't the Democrats say I'm a fucking Clintonism?
They don't.
Because the Republicans did such a fucking great job at,
by the way,
in a,
an amazing politician and a consensus politician being destroyed because he
liked to fuck.
Well,
people help them other than the Republicans.
The goddamn Democrats helped him.
Women helped him.
Democrat men who are pussies and white knights,
they helped him.
Everybody helped.
They all pointed at him.
I wouldn't do that.
Why you fucked up?
Maybe it would.
Maybe you will have.
You're a fat guy with a giant penis nose.
It was all of a sudden president and everybody wants to touch you.
Yeah,
you probably do some crazy shit.
Probably can't even believe you're doing it.
And while you're doing,
you probably can't believe when you're alone.
They shut that door.
Good evening,
Mr President,
have a good night.
They shut that door and you're alone in the oval office,
like get the fuck.
But it started before that.
I was reading this amazing article recently about like Hillary Clinton and the
Clinton presidency and the lead up to the Clinton presidency and it was like,
they have been implicated in murders.
They've been implicated in,
they were there,
was pushed for impeachment sex with men,
sex with women,
uh,
you know,
scandals,
uh,
over millions of dollars.
And you're like,
that's how it's a card shit.
Well,
who knows?
It's true,
but you know what it is.
It doesn't matter if it's true because perception is reality.
But what,
what is true is there's a fucking PR war with,
with all those.
What's the,
what's the thing on a,
on a house of cards?
The A,
I haven't watched that show.
I just watched the first episode.
It's so fucking good.
Don't feel good boiler.
But anyway,
all the,
all this sort of PR shit that goes on.
Oh,
if you fuck with me and don't vote for this,
I'm going to PR attack you and I'm going to get my soup back to attack you on
this shit.
And I'm going to do this whenever tech.
And,
and the thing is,
is what's interesting is they're taking real life shit that's happening in
American politics and they put it into like a thing that we can understand.
I love it.
I don't like a lot of the,
the gay socks.
No,
that I love.
the tricky sort of directorial chicks.
But what I do love is taking real life shit and saying,
here's,
here's what's actually happening and we're going to put it into a drum.
And it's actually like Shakespeare.
It's like Macbeth or something.
And we're watching our own politics as a play and it's insane.
And when you read actually what,
what they,
what they've been through,
what they've done.
And by the way,
what's good for the goose is good for them.
They're not fucking,
they're not,
they're not blaming
less.
Of course,
there's no one's playing on no one's blameless.
No.
Right.
No everybody,
no Aryans Green party.
100%
they're all freaks.
And by the way,
if you're running for politics,
you're a freak.
Full Stop.
Well,
that's,
I think also one of the reasons why nobody wants to get behind the Clintons.
As you start looking into their past,
the Whitewater stuff and Whitewater,
is that the right name?
Is that the right term?
I don't know,
but I know what you mean when you say it.
Watergate.
Yeah.
Whitewater Watergate was Nixon white one.
I get the two of them confused sometimes,
but um,
did you ever read this strange death of Vince foster?
No,
but I read about the fact that they were implicated in a,
in a death.
Yeah.
The strange death of Vince foster.
What are you doing over there?
Death of Vince foster.
I might have very interesting,
a very interesting book that I read.
A,
I really have to go back and reread it because I haven't read it in a long time,
but a,
it's an investigation of um,
this guy,
Vince foster and Vince foster worked with the Clintons and it tied bill and
Hillary Clinton to the alleged events and foster.
And what's really interesting about this,
for sure,
this fucking guy for sure was moved.
They found his body gun in the hand,
which you never find a suicide.
The gun has never in your hand when you commit suicide,
when you commit suicide,
boom,
the gun goes flying,
your fucking body spasms.
This gun was like stuck to his thumb.
Like they're,
you know,
Susan,
the thing and his body aside,
murders,
this is how's the car?
I'm not going to fuck with you on it,
but we got to stop talking about cause it's House the card shit.
Well I want to watch that show is pretty,
but you know,
it's about that shit.
It's about like they're involved in some seriously and you're like watching this
thing saying it's like Shakespeare and it's like whatever.
Like it's a,
it's a it Hollywood.
And then you read actually what happened and you go,
oh fuck.
Like that's,
there's some truth to that.
The only problem with this,
it's I think a lot of it was compiled,
uh,
Kenneth Starr's investigate other same Kenneth Starr's investigation was part of
the conspiracy star was a patsy for the Clintonites.
And when people think about Kenneth Star,
they think about a guy who goes after Clinton,
right?
I mean,
he was part of,
what was it?
Wasn't he the guy that was investigating Clinton and chasing after him with
Monica Lewinsky,
but they're calling him a patsy for the Clintons.
I don't know,
man.
The whole,
the whole fucking thing is when you start realizing like,
oh,
they all might all might be murderers.
There might be just par for the course,
just like these people.
Anyone just think of this.
Anyone who's willing to say,
yes,
we should go to war on some shaky grounds.
You're a murderer.
But also anyone who's saying,
I'm going to go and try to get elected and not have any bad shit from my life
ever come out.
I don't know anyone in my life that I've ever met that hasn't had some,
well,
the only way you can do that is to kill people that no bad shit about you or
scare the fuck out of them.
So they can't come up with all that bad shit.
Exactly.
And I mean he,
they were involved in some shady real estate deals.
There was a,
first of all,
the big one is Mena Arkansas.
Do you know about all that?
Do you know about MENA?
Arkansas is a fucking trip,
man.
Mena Arkansas was where Barry seal,
who we work for.
The CIA was dropping all the cocaine that he got from South America.
They would fly in on these fucking planes and drop packages off in Mena,
Arkansas and then land and they'd go pick up the packages while they drop these
packages.
You know,
the drop in fucking millions of dollars where the cocaine and these kids who
lived in Mena,
Arkansas,
we're hanging out on these train tracks.
They found these packages,
the the people,
whoever the fuck worked for the CIA found these kids,
murdered them and then laid their body on the train tracks.
The autopsies were done,
the kids were high,
they fell asleep on the train tracks.
Parents didn't believe it.
They said,
look,
these kids didn't get high.
This is bullshit.
So they hired an independent investigation.
The Independent investigation finds that the kids had been murdered,
the kids had been stabbed.
Okay.
So that wasn't a matter of them dying from train tracks.
Their bodies were laid on the train.
It's postmortem.
So then they start digging deeper and they find out more and more shit.
And then this guy,
Barry seal gets popped and it turns out the Barry seal had been flying back and
forth from the fucking South American coke dealers for a RAF are,
hold on a second.
Is this,
he died.
See,
they murdered him in his car when he was on his way to testify with George Bush,
his phone number in his fucking pocket.
Okay.
That guy,
that guy literally sold drugs for the CIA,
like literally like testify,
gave all these accounts of the rights to this story.
Oh,
you'll never hear it.
There's all these pictures of him with all these South American guys,
like fucking uh,
what's his name?
Manuel Noriega and Pablo Escobar's photos of this fucking guy with everybody.
They were bringing in Koch money and this is all happening in Arkansas that,
that uh,
that Duh,
the guy who's state is bringing in fucking kazillion dollars in Koch money.
Every winds up.
First of all,
how the fuck do you run a shitbag state like arc and,
sorry,
sorry.
No offense,
Arkansas folks.
I'm sure there's some good spots and I'm sure you've got great barbecue,
but let's be realistic.
How the fuck does the governor of Arkansas wind up to be the,
the,
the king of the entire country of the month?
You got to get a lot of of money and if you had a lot of money,
why would you be running for office in Arkansas?
What's Arkansas and why you in or I've got a question,
what's going on?
If you had that much money,
our takes pieces on get,
don't get assigned,
it takes billions of dollars.
I don't really mean to run for president of the United States.
Billions,
billions.
If you're,
if you have that much money or that much support,
why the fuck would you want that Gig?
Because I don't know any president besides Reagan,
but which by the way is uh,
uh,
construct.
Cause when he was in power it was a fucking disaster.
But you go,
okay,
like why would you want that job?
No one comes out unscathed.
No one comes out like,
you know what?
That fucking president was awesome.
Well Reagan,
are you going to come out on,
no,
no.
He came out,
fuck he exists.
He was a dog until we said,
you know,
when he was the best one ever.
But the thing is,
is you sit there and go,
why they're going to put everything you've ever done under a microscope that
you've ever met is under a microscope.
Everything you've ever said is under micro.
Why the fuck would you want that fucking job?
Well,
not only that,
I mean that's,
that's certainly gotta be impossible.
An impossible task for any normal human being,
especially a man.
Any,
any man with a functional penis.
He's going to have some fucking terrible stories in his past.
But that said,
forget about all that.
The idea that any one person should be like that is what's most ridiculous.
Exactly.
The idea that they're going to look all this stuff up and us.
And then there's the idea that he killed somebody.
Jk.
Just chick.
Yeah,
just shake her.
Just the idea that one person really can run the whole kind of like,
we need a head guy.
Like why do we need a head guy?
Do we really still need that?
I don't know.
But what I'm saying is to get there,
those mother fuckers have to be shady because if you look at like George Bush
Sr,
he was like a backroom bureaucrat buddy was head of the CIA.
He's like our fucking Putin.
And then he,
he gets in and he's just like this sort of non effectual sort of like nothing
fucking dude.
But he's like,
he's like the head of the fucking CIA and you sit there and he'd just go,
I don't even know what the fuck's happening here anymore.
I don't know what you're writing over there.
What happens if president's become like tuna?
Like we get to the point where nobody wants to be president.
I don't want to be like fuck this point where there's like literally no one
running for president.
We have the presidential elections today and everybody's like,
cause people,
whenever I do like political pieces of shit,
they're like,
you should by the way,
I've seen it with you too.
Like on Twitter and shit.
They're like,
you should run for office.
You guys should run for office.
Usually Joe Rogan for president,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And you're like,
are you fucking crazy?
Well,
not only that,
forget about fucking crease.
What kind of a fucking stressful job?
Even if you were the most perfect Yoda,
Buddha Angel that made it to age 45 and never did a crime and never smoked a
joint and never did a bump,
whatever,
you know,
even if you were,
what kind of crazy pressure would that be to all of a sudden you're the guy
who's deciding whether or not military action takes place.
You're the guy who's deciding whether or not a policy is going to be instituted
like Obamacare that people get up and walk that responsibility.
I don't,
dude.
If you make a youtube video that people don't like,
they want you to die.
Could you imagine what it must feel like to be the guy who invented Obamacare?
I have personally seen people freak the fuck out,
get purple faced,
sweat flying off their head,
talking about the nonsense that is Obamacare.
I don't understand it.
I don't know who's right.
I don't.
I,
I'm not a small business owner in that sense where they have a higher,
you know,
a bunch of people and pay for their,
I don't know what's good and what's bad.
I don't know even,
I don't even understand why it was instituted in the first place.
I'm not sure I totally get it cause I've heard too many different versions of it
out.
I was supposed to do something.
By the way,
this is like the last week,
like you have one you guys are taking care of.
You don't have to worry about any of that.
We have to like say yes or no do it because they make it seem like you're going
to get fine if you don't get that right.
It's I think for individuals,
I'm not sure how it works but I know that you guys always had insurance so I
think it's essentially the same insurance.
This is essentially the same.
I don't think,
I don't think it's any different knows so many people are going to get fine and
it's going to be the most money that governments ever made.
Well we don't have to get bogged down because I'll just go off for hours about
this.
So,
but what I was just saying is that I don't think anybody should have that kind
of responsibility.
I think any person should have the weight of the world like that on their back.
I think there has to be a better way to collectively decide what's going on.
Then to give one guy white hair.
It's crazy.
Horror motherfuckers,
man.
Nobody can do that Gig.
Here's a guy.
He's you,
man.
How old are you?
44 he's just a little older than you.
That's nonsense.
I don't know about that because older people are even more crazy.
Absolutely crazy like to say is I agree with you that we're going to vote a
collective me to try to make those decisions because there is no collective me.
What I mean by he's you and he's the same age.
What I mean is it's,
I'm just putting it into perspective that I don't feel anyone ever is the guy.
100% can't be done.
Okay.
It's a proposition.
He's going to go toe to toe with Putin over Crimea.
What does that,
if I'm going to go toe to toe with fruit and overcome,
yeah.
I'm going to say,
you know what?
I lost because that guy used to run the KGB.
He's
got all the guys on the ground with all their weapons.
He's already won.
He's got a consent.
What the fuck am I going to do?
Who would you stop it?
Could you imagine if they had Obama,
if they did something to Obama?
Like could you imagine if something happened where like,
well,
you know that guy that got poisoned in,
in Russia and Ukraine,
Ukraine,
yeah.
Face turned in this horrible,
it was horrible,
horrible poison.
Like the guy came very close to dot.
Well,
I don't know about all,
but what I'm saying allegedly was brutal.
Could you imagine if we found out that some,
you know,
not even Putin,
some crazy person out there had it in for a mama and was actually going after
him.
Like,
I'm sure there's a thousand.
We've never had an American president assassinated by anyone in a foreign
country.
And the closest to was blaming or from a foreign country blaming Lee Harvey
Oswald who had gone to the Soviet Union for killing Kennedy,
but other guys who've killed presidents before,
whether it is a Abraham Lincoln or how many,
how many presidents have been assassinated?
Was it three?
Why are you asking me?
You don't know.
You're not even from my country.
I figure they,
you have to learn those things for a
dress.
That was either way.
I don't think anyone has ever been any of the murders.
Relatively small.
We're blamed on a foreign enemy.
Right.
So fascinating man.
The idea that there might be a new war cooking and it might be with Russia.
Well,
I've been saying this for a number of years.
Thank you very much.
I go to Russia and I'm like,
what the fuck's going on?
Because I went there and I said,
I don't understand.
I don't get the politics.
What?
What is Putin like?
Is he calming it?
Cause the communists like him.
Is he sort of right wing as he left wing?
No,
no,
no.
He's,
he's Pro Russia and you're like,
okay,
I get these pro-Russian everyone's pro fucking,
whenever the countries did from what the fuck is his Baltic's because the
communist support him,
the fucking fascist supportive.
Everyone supports them and,
and he's like,
no,
he's Pro Russia.
He's anti West.
So Pro Russia equals anti west.
And when you go there,
you realize these people a whole generation of more now because the new
generation were,
it was the Cold War.
It was like we on our side,
we're like,
oh commies eat babies and you can buy a house for a pair of blue jeans.
All that horse shit.
They grew up on all that being like American gangsters fucking,
you know.
And so what happens is Putin comes along and just goes,
yeah,
America.
Fuck.
It's not our economic crisis.
It's America's economic crisis.
They fucked us up.
It's not us being fucking new oil bitches.
It's Saudi Arabia who run is run by America.
The Cold War rhetoric in Russia never stopped.
That's the one thing that we never,
we don't realize here they are saying America is to blame for all of our shit.
Ever stop or did it take a break and then rekindle with Putin?
It took a small break with Yeltsin and then boom,
this guy was hanging out.
Well,
Putin has been in like 16 years now.
Do you remember in Yeltsin would like come over and he was hearing out,
was he,
was he the guy that Gorbachev,
Gorbachev,
Gorbachev started it.
Yeltsin took over,
pushed it real fast.
Everyone loved him because he was a democracy dude.
He started all the oligarchs.
Putin was head of KGB.
He came in and now has been basically running shit for a long time.
But the interesting thing about Putin is now he's just like,
fuck you.
I don't know if you saw the Crimean address,
but he's like,
you guys put it up on us.
NATO put it up on us.
You guys put your missile defense systems along our borders.
Fuck you.
Crimea's ours.
You want to go to war?
That's go.
It's like he's been sort of training in silent,
like I'm going to fucking punch the punching bag and get ready and now he's
ready to go.
And this is this whole thing in the north.
It's here,
it's Crimea.
He's like,
I don't give a fuck what you say.
I don't give a fuck about the west.
I don't give a fuck about America.
I don't give a fuck about your sanctions.
And this is why we're going back to this cold war rhetoric.
That's not even cold war rhetoric.
It's beyond cold war rhetoric cause he's like fuck you,
I don't give a shit.
What you say now is this,
because he's looking out for Russia and Russia's in a bad economic situation and
Russia needs all that oil.
I mean oil,
they have oil,
they have tons of oral,
they have ties there all day.
In fact,
all of the energy in the Ukraine is supplied by Russia.
The majority of natural gas going into Western Europe is from Russia.
So what's going on here?
What is the underlying motive for why?
Why this is escalated?
Well,
Mia has been their only fresh water port since Peter the Great.
So that's the only place they can get to the rest of the world.
And someone else ran it and they didn't like that.
The Ukraine,
Ukraine.
If you draw a line,
the,
the western part is pro Europe,
the eastern part is pro Russia.
So they said,
well fuck you,
we're just going to take it back.
And what happened is they did the same thing in Georgia.
They're all of the old
Soviet republics are,
they're now taking back and Crimea is,
is,
has been,
they,
they've wanted it because it's strategically important to them for their naval
base,
but basically they just cut a big chunk of Europe,
quote unquote Europe out and said it's ours now.
And we went,
yeah,
okay.
So we just don't want to start any bolts.
We can't,
we can't,
nothing we can do unless we're going to go to,
what are you going to do?
It's like saying New Jersey says they don't want to be part of fucking America.
So Russia moved in and we're gonna fucking right.
Right,
right.
Can't have,
yeah,
that would be interesting.
Yeah.
Of Russia said we can't take New Jersey.
Exactly.
And then,
and then by the way,
what are you going to do send in troops and like what is it going to take for
our culture to move past all of these things that are holding us back?
Like this kind of gangster behavior that all countries do.
Not just the United States,
not just Russia.
Pretty much any country that has a lot of power.
They just decide like they need some resources.
They decide they need this,
they need that.
I mean it's,
it's always been,
what did you know?
It's a really complicated sort of propaganda.
I agree with you.
I say that the only way we have any real power is consumer advocacy.
What does that mean?
Whatever we buy,
that's the power because that's economics.
Economics runs everything and as long as Europe is buying Russian energy,
then Russia is going to say,
I'm going to do whatever the fuck I want.
Russia is redrawing the borders of Europe with Europe's money,
right?
Yeah.
Cause they sell the gas to,
to Europe.
We're in the exact same position,
right.
We were sitting there saying,
okay,
well we're going to do this and we're going to die.
Why?
Because we use Google because we use fucking Facebook because we buy Nike's
because we buy forward.
Because whatever,
what's going to happen is people realize whatever I buy,
that's the real power.
If you want.
And when I say that,
what I mean is if you look at pre 2008 number one sellers escalate hummer,
you know,
all the big SUV post 2008 Prius,
right?
Because all of a sudden gas fucking tripled in price.
So the only thing that really moves policy is how people vote with the dollars.
Because if you fucking start voting with dollars with Unilever,
with Procter and gamble,
with Ford,
with GM,
with Exxon,
then you're going to move policy.
You could move policy decisions tomorrow,
tomorrow,
because these guys have lives to power and they say,
fuck these people aren't buying Fords anymore.
They're not buying Exxon gas or nothing.
Whatever.
The idea that that oil is,
so it fluctuates so much has always been baffling to me.
It doesn't fluctuate that much.
But yeah,
but it,
but it fluctuates.
It fluctuates between profit and crazy profit.
Well,
do you remember when,
um,
you were talking about the gas hike,
you remember there was right when Bush was leaving office when George W was
leaving office and right when he was leaving office it became like this weird
feeling like the,
the,
the gas was sell expensive.
That it came like this weird feeling like people who weren't conspiracy
theorists were going,
wait,
are we getting fucked?
Like is he leaving?
And in the process as he just does,
he have like some crazy three month grace period where they just start socking
money out people because it just started going up and up and up and you're like,
well I'm sorry we have to pass on this law of loss to the consumer oils more
expensive these days.
Wait a minute.
What is the why is,
well,
Mark's friend said,
what exactly is going on?
Why is it Cohen coincidentally coinciding with you leaving office?
Like we couldn't dig into that,
then that would be very difficult to pull off today.
If the same situation when it was happening today,
it would be much harder to pull off 10 years from now,
more difficult,
20 years from now.
Impossible.
That's what I think.
I think that all this creepy shit that they've been able to do and fuck people
over and clandestine operations like that,
I think they can't.
It's like you can't hide it anymore.
And that's why there's some magic.
I was like Edward Snowden.
That's why they're so mad at guys like Julian Assange.
Just like those guys,
they broke the first holes in the dike and the water's coming through.
I don't mean that kind of type.
Right?
If you look at it,
you say if you,
if you look at after nine 11,
the Saudi royal family,
uh,
who were living here in America were flown out.
Why?
Because whenever we have problems with,
uh,
oil prices,
we just go to Saudi and say,
make more and then the prices come down just because they own the most reserves,
the easy stuff.
The beautiful crude.
When was that?
What year is that?
One?
8,008 wow,
that's crazy.
So what happens is if we,
if we have a problem with supply,
we go to Saudi and say,
w w what OPEC should have been,
which was how can we drive prices up?
Saudi Arabia actually de neutered because they said,
okay,
we're going to fucking drive prices down whenever the state say yes.
That's what's interesting because that's why alcaide exists because we are Saudi
Arabia's friend and we and we use them to go up and down bin Laden who comes
from one of the fucking richest families in Saudi Arabia said,
fuck you.
I'm not gonna.
You know,
we're the land of Mecca Medina.
We are the land of fucking Islamic purity.
We're not going to count out to the Americans.
That's where it all comes from.
It all comes from Saudi Arabia because of oil.
And because we forced them to,
to,
you know,
lower oil prices,
which makes us money,
which then they see it as we're in cahoots and then boom.
That's why there's a resentment when you find out about these small countries
that were doing terrible up until oil production and they became
like this most incredible magical land where everything is essentially free.
Yeah.
I mean the amount of wealth that people in those areas
and not crazy long period of time,
a fairly short period of time is when you look at human history.
All of the sudden
history.
Yeah.
Modern culture.
Anything really.
Essentially one of the,
Gabby,
if you fly into Abu Dabi,
which has the two largest mosques in the world,
you fly in and there's a picture from 1957 and it's a mud fort and like four
huts and then you drive into Abu Dabi now,
which looks like Las Vegas on steroids in fucking 50 years.
They've built New York.
Well,
some,
someone on my message board had that point.
So they were saying,
you know,
uh,
that I always go on and on about the pyramids.
I'm fascinated about the pyramids.
And some guy showed this aerial photo of Dubai and he was like,
fuck the pyramids man.
Look how crazy this shit is.
I was like nothing.
Yeah,
yeah.
50 years.
It went from zero a mud hut to yeah,
he's got a point,
you know,
one one day if we ever found Dubai,
if we,
I mean what it's the,
the more impressive aspect of the Egyptian pyramids is we don't understand how
they were built.
We don't get it.
So we look at the,
they just the sheer size and the numbers of stones and we're like,
fuck,
how'd they do that?
But what happened?
What happened to the voice it pop out,
check,
check their cost.
Um,
but the,
the difference between like the amount of structures they have and say like,
no,
that happened.
Why I felt the a,
the sound stop my ear.
It's just the court clips.
Great.
No,
no,
it didn't get it.
Don't worry.
I almost got my laptop.
I'm a fucking fool for this paper trash right here.
Right to the right idea.
Um,
anyway,
where were we?
Pyramids.
Oh yeah,
we're getting it flew over Manhattan.
Manhattan was abandoned in the desert.
It would be like 10 times more insane than finding the pyramids because the
structures,
there's so many of them.
What I find crazy about pyramids and actually bronze age weapons is that we
can't build weapons like that anymore.
Like what weapons?
There was a a thing you know was watching so therefore it has to be true because
it was on TV about Bronze Age swords that were like,
it's so insanely strong cause I always thought,
you know they were shitty like led swords or copper swords or whatever.
They had bronze age armor in bronze age shorts and they would shoot like a
bronze age armored vest with like a modern day rifle and it wouldn't,
it couldn't,
it couldn't penetrate it.
And I was like how the fuck is that even possible?
That sounds like nonsense.
No it isn't nonsense.
And swords that are like still bronze age swords that can cut through like
crazy.
I see.
It sounds like nonsense.
Now that I say,
can you do me a favor?
You're just laughing right up.
Can you do me a favor?
Look up bronze age armor slash bronze age weaponry.
That's just nonsense on,
well hold on.
Fetish tell until fucking I get verification.
I'm not,
well they certainly spent a lot of time making weapons back then that you know,
that they,
uh,
I mean they didn't spend,
I don't know how we've devolved into fighting over bronze age weaponry.
I was definitely not my number one,
the sphere of expertise.
How much time do you think it must have?
They must have spent like building a Samurai sword.
All the times.
Lines.
Yeah,
because
what I was about to bring it up with you,
is
this what you want right here,
right.
Bronze Age sort.
But what I want you to do is,
is there's gotta be an article about Bronze Age weaponry being more
sophisticated than modern day weapon.
That's silly.
How's that?
Guns and shit.
Yeah,
exactly.
Hmm.
Well maybe with our modern day bronze cause we figured out bronze cost suck.
Well,
correct.
Moved on some better shit.
There's,
but there's a thing about like Bronze Age,
uh,
armor.
Okay.
What is the thing that it's super strong.
I don't want to get too far off on this because I'm not,
I just,
I read a thing about it.
That's all.
Well,
I believe that they certainly had some knowledge flows and swords and there's a
lot of weapons that they constructed back then that were pretty advanced.
You know,
they figured out some shit.
I had to think that we were gonna.
I was gonna fucking bring it up out of Boston.
I've had a few ales.
This is the problem with the end of our God damn snow problems are podcasts is
I'm now,
I'm fine.
And what do you guys think about the uh,
the pastor that recently died?
They,
that guy that,
oh,
all the gate.
Right?
Do you think that it's a d the gays and everyone should like attack his funeral?
Why or do you think they should show the fire ground or take the higher ground?
What do you,
what do you think?
That's a ridiculous question.
Of course he shouldn't attack his funeral.
We should ignore that.
It might shock their whole family and their phone call to be like,
Oh shit,
now I see what you're talking about.
That's fucked up.
No,
no,
we're HIPAA.
You'd be a hypocrite.
And also you're not going to shock their family.
Their family was under the,
the,
like they were under the reign of a dictator or like a religious dictator,
an old cunt.
He was an old crazy asshole who screamed at people and scared the fuck out of
them and had them all believing that his way was the only way God hates fags
guy.
Right.
He's got it holds up to science.
Okay.
He's just a crazy old
dude that's all a house of cards and I don't know this
Westboro Baptist church,
it's pretty bad.
I'm going to put up my hand because I know we wrote a lot of stuff about it for
advice,
but I have,
I'm not,
I don't know shit about it.
Um,
anyway,
the bottom line is that the guy was an asshole.
Now he's dead.
It's just,
it's unfortunate that people get roped into that sort of a hateful
organizationally,
you know,
my whole thing is it takes all sorts.
I don't know what you do over in your compound and I don't know what,
yeah,
because this guy would go out and attack people who would go out and they would,
you know,
protest funerals.
I get what I'm saying is he was going out there being a bad guy.
I'm saying I don't,
I don't try to look at my neighbors next door yard and oh like he was doing or
saying or anybody does.
Yeah,
well you know what man,
it's just sad when people get people or some people are like easily led and
instead of finding some,
you know,
nice religious leaders,
you'll put together a nice community and they all have picnics and shit.
If they found an asshole,
I mean that's really essentially what happened.
They got roped into some shitheads gravity and a and now he's dead.
Yeah,
they definitely shouldn't protest this funeral man.
Just just,
you know he's,
he's a lesson.
You're just trying to start shit legit question.
I believe in dynamic fasteners and all that.
Karma hype like positive stuff dynamic faster.
I just think that,
what are you talking about?
People they want faster.
He blew a point.
Oh what is it?
Dynamic fastener or something that that he's like a huge sponsor for all these
UFC fighters.
Right,
but what is it?
[inaudible] it's just a part,
it's like screws and bolts.
But this guy's just a big UFC fan and he just pays for all these.
Right.
But it's just like,
just say that no one's gonna know what the fuck you're talking about.
I didn't know what you're talking about.
I mean I've seen the ads but I didn't,
I had no idea what your case.
I don't know what,
I never,
I never looked into what that was.
It's really interesting because the guy's just a fan and then you realize it's
not that expensive to be a sponsor for one of these fighters.
So this guy that just owns like,
I like this part co guy and he's just a fan said now everyone was like coming
out in shirts with like this is dynamic fastener on it and it's just like
nothing.
It's nothing that
ego does that to a technologies guy does that.
I asked him once and was like,
why?
Why do you advertise field?
So I just log it like seeing,
I think it was like the real world or something and it was like the biggest show
on TV at the time.
And it would show at like three in the morning when most people would get home
in New York.
And there was the guy that Brooklyn clown,
it's Brooklyn clown.
He was a clown,
but it would be like the number one show on TV.
But people would come home at like three in the morning and he was a clown who
would buy like the advertising spots for like a grand and so it was this huge
show that millions of people would watch.
But all the advertising would be about the Brooklyn town.
Huh?
It's actually really cheap to get advertising in late at night.
That's what I was trying to get.
Like Tito's Tacos.
Seriously.
You know how many of you were saying you were saying the the fastener can,
I can get,
get in there and get the thing.
This guy was super smart cause he's like,
oh here's this time slot that everyone's getting home to watch the real world or
whatever.
Some big show.
Wow.
Where does it,
when they give away their whole channel,
how can they have a fake show?
There you go.
That's the weirdest shit ever.
You're like,
am I Montel Williams?
Is this a real show?
Montel,
what's going on here?
Merging 30 years.
He got right in judo.
No.
10 he got 10 years ago.
10 only.
Yeah.
Have you done a mirror?
No,
cause I wouldn't have mine that would never have that guy on like,
well because I watch,
it's a lot of those were swindler I met him.
He's a nice guy.
I met him because he um,
yeah,
he put a bunch of money into something called the Ip t was the international
pool tour and uh,
he um,
he put on these gigantic events in Vegas.
Like the most money people ever got paid from professional pool was Kevin
Trudeau.
Yup.
And he put together a television show and he was going to have these guys play
and it was on television and they were playing pool for hundreds of thousands of
dollars.
They,
they had done it full blast.
Like he put the pedal to the metal,
spent millions of bucks that he'd robbed from little old ladies,
thought they were going to lose weight secrets they don't want you to know
about.
But he spent all this money under the premise that there was laws that,
um,
that hadn't been instituted yet.
Um,
they didn't,
they didn't know that they existed.
They were going to ride them about Internet gambling.
So when they made these,
when they made the business model,
they factored in internet gambling people be able to gamble on these pool
matches and will profit from that.
And then there'll be residual.
I have a bunch of gambling junkies associate are our site with a good place to
gamble.
You know,
because there was all these online gambling,
poker players,
all those people that got arrested and had to move to Costa Rica.
Yeah,
well this was all part of that.
Okay.
So when they came in and shut down online gambling,
he was fucked.
So he lost shitloads of money.
Oh,
I'm spilled again.
How to give people their money back.
Had to,
had to pay off these pool players and like fractions on the dollar.
I mean,
I don't know what the fraction was.
It was 75 cents on a dollar.
Or if some of them got paid all their money,
but he didn't pay all of them.
I don't know.
Maybe they all got paid eventually,
but it's a long struggle you're talking about,
right.
So this guy,
interesting shit.
So then,
um,
you know,
the pool takes this big fucking slide afterwards,
but everybody sorta hopes and prays that this guy gets his shit together and
comes back to pool.
He's like the savior,
a pool that's fucking crazy.
Guy Rips off all ladies.
I actually want it
do that story is a movie that's the most fascinating cause he,
he did this pool thing,
blew up in his face and he said I'm going to cure cancer with no,
no.
He always had the nonsense.
The nonsense was always there.
He always had nonsense.
He is the nonsense to make his money.
Cause I,
I get home at like four in the morning,
so I watch late night infomercials and I'm,
I'm a,
I'm weak at that.
Our strongest,
no,
I'm not the strongest mentally.
Oh,
I see.
I don't know why that came up.
We totally let down a dark road because the one of these hiccups,
you're wasted.
Right.
And you,
and he's going,
you know what?
It's fucking powdered asparagus.
That's what's going to do it.
I'm like,
you know what?
I'm in coral calcium.
Remember
coral cow?
That was the one that was the one that you got to know.
It's coral counseling.
He's Japanese people that I would have fucking dead.
I would've put it in my eyeballs.
Yeah.
Cause it's four 30 in the morning.
You're ready to go.
You're like,
fuck,
I want coral calcium.
It seems like what's something that's missing in my life?
Yeah.
I need that.
When it's really late at night,
you're like,
you're convinced he got fuck though.
Yeah.
10 years is a long ass time.
And uh,
you know,
he had done some time already,
had done like a few months.
They tried to tell the judge that he's changed his ways,
get,
you know,
we got to do his,
we got a wolf of Wall Street.
That shit.
Well,
you know,
I have a,
a good friend who worked for him for years.
Fuck off.
Yeah.
Let's make that.
If you want it,
you gotta do it right now.
I don't know.
Everybody we want to do the movie stopped.
I don't know if my friends signed the NDA,
so I have to be careful about Trudeau doesn't get out of jail and throw heat at
them.
He might fucking escape.
Even if he told the story.
Truthfully though,
the store would be Shawshank door.
The truthful story is actually quite fascinating.
You know,
the,
the actual truthful story of him spending all that money on pool fucking brain
acts because pool players or a fuck a bunch of maniacs,
crazy guys out there scrambling and hustling and wearing fucking wearing
overalls and pretending they just hopped off a farm.
Just anybody who,
I don't know.
Yeah,
I mean that's what half of those guys grew up doing.
You know?
That's how for those guys,
that's where they get their,
uh,
that's where they get their experience,
you know?
And so all of a sudden they're wearing tuxedos and they're playing on TV.
And it was one of those weird TV channels too.
It was like it was on one of those burgeoning,
we have to make a movie.
This fucker.
It's interesting stuff man.
They were good events too.
He really taught us players in the world.
It's also like a global news event that this fucker got like 10 years.
Yeah.
So anyway.
Oh boy.
Shouldn't talk about it anymore.
But we should make this fuck.
Listen man,
you should make the movie and I'll tell you what the story,
I'll connect you to people and I'm awesome movies,
man.
I ain't got no time for that.
Ain't nobody got time for that.
Um,
that uh,
that story is kind of unique though.
It's any unique.
Also,
day off school is a tragic fucking game.
It's a tragically a haunted game and I'm not exactly sure why.
It seems like somewhere along the line pool,
fuck somebody over and well,
it's first of all,
it didn't fuck anyone over.
It's a barroom game that you bet your pitcher money on [inaudible] and all of a
sudden it was like legitimate because of a awful but amazing Tom cruise movie.
And then you're like,
why isn't it Nuka?
Well,
it was way bigger.
You know,
before the Tom Cruise movie in the 19 hundreds it turn of the century,
there was a thousand,
no,
no pool.
There was a thousand pool halls in New York City at the turn of the century.
Pool was huge.
And know the term pool doesn't mean pocket billiards.
Pocket billiards is the game,
right?
The term pool is gathering up all your money and betting it,
pooling your money together and betting it on games.
So pool was the name pool.
In fact,
it was inherently connected to this derelict bachelor lifestyle.
Why?
Cause I got you on the subject.
The only thing that you know,
like he knows more about [inaudible] except for pool.
Well there's a lot of people know a lot more about pool than I do,
but I know enough.
I know enough.
In 1962 is when it became really famous though.
It was the hustler,
a hustler.
The motherfucking Gleason.
That's a fair play.
His ass off.
Jack [inaudible] really good for real.
Paul Newman was making,
he paid,
he played uh,
Minnesota fats.
And then,
and then,
uh,
Paul Newman lost to but then B,
I was thinking about that.
I can't be beat tonight.
That just that line.
Cause I was,
I was on a roll.
I was fucking people's Shit,
whatever it,
I was like,
I can't be beat tonight.
And I was like,
where's that from?
This is my table man.
I own it.
Be Paul Newman.
Paul Newman couldn't play a lick,
but they knew it was terrible.
But you could tell he couldn't really play.
It was offensive to a real pool player.
He watches goofy stroke and shots of,
you'd mentioned chat out of here with that fucking combination bank shot.
That's,
that's,
that's nonsense.
Hope today shoots that shot.
So you're going to say that.
What about Tom Cruise?
He could play.
Really?
Yeah.
Tom Cruise.
Fuck off.
He apprenticed with Mike Segal,
Mike Segal,
who's a multiple time world champion and also was a lefty like Tom Cruise.
who was a friend of mine,
brilliant pool player,
like literally one of the greatest of all time.
And he mentor Tom Cruise has taught him [inaudible] Tom Cruise is a maniac.
He fucking took that dude and he taught him how to play and he looks like a pool
player.
It doesn't look like a great pool player.
There's a fluidity of my really good at something.
I have an open bridge,
so I'm going to tell a true story.
When I was a young kid,
there's a lot of pool playing in,
in a Muncho like for money.
And I had a girlfriend who was a girl and she would grow in a friend and she was
a fantastic pool player.
Huh.
So she would win.
But she was like,
if you ever see anyone who has an open bridge,
you've won.
That was the whole thing.
Like,
all right.
And so Paul Newman as an open Brit.
Well that does,
that's not really correct.
There's a lot of really great players.
Rob Cya is one of the best in the world.
I'll plays almost exclusively with an open bridge.
Very rarely closest bridge.
She just prefers to cite the queue that way.
And once you get really good,
it doesn't matter.
There's certain shots where some guys prefer close bridge,
but there's some great snooker players that never closed their bridge.
All the guys that came over from snuck her sneakers all done with an open bridge
and they have the best fundamentals out of almost any cool so far in the fucking
pockets.
Tiny pockets,
tiny balls,
precise card.
So the mechanics have to be absolutely perfect.
So snooker players have,
are you a better fighter,
a pool player?
This point in my life,
but I suck at both at this point where I ever get both.
No,
I suck at book.
You're like,
what?
Are you leaning fine?
You know,
like five times?
No,
no,
no.
Taekwondo champion.
A state championship.
I won four years in a row,
but that was 98819891999 or whenever it was [inaudible] 85 to 88 so you're one
of the best
lovers,
taekwondo guys.
I know how to drive you better.
Are you better at cooler taekwondo?
Come on.
I was definitely better at talking window.
Okay.
Yeah,
I was way better.
I pool a pool.
I got marginal at best a pool.
I'm a decent,
what do you call it?
Beat player.
Did you play for money?
Yeah,
it's fun.
It's fun.
You know I'm not good enough to beat anybody.
That's actually good.
Pool is something that you have to literally play eight hours a day.
Can you,
can you win right off the rack?
What do you mean?
Can I run out?
Yeah,
I can run out.
I just not that consistent.
Right.
I can break and run out but I might not do it the next game.
I might miss it.
You really need to like put in the numbers,
the hours because what you're doing when you're playing,
when you get really good is you,
you are so in tuned with the amount of effort that it takes to knock your stick
into this ball that you're literally counting the revolutions with field that
the ball's going to make.
It's like archery and a lot of ways and in that when you're actually executing,
it requires absolute complete concentration and there's something that's very
attractive to me about anything that requires absolute complete concentration.
Whether it's martial arts,
whether it's pool,
weather,
it's archery.
I think there's something deeper that's going on.
I think my brain is recognizing that it needs,
it needs some fixing.
10th stimulation.
The Hustler and color of money is when they're going,
there's a rhythm [inaudible] they're just popping.
Yeah,
he was doing it.
And when they're not,
they're like,
oh,
I'm hitting shots.
Right?
But when he's gone,
he's like,
I can't be beat,
motherfucker.
Well,
did you ever see there's a scene in the hustler where he plays this guy or a,
in the color of money we placed this Guy Greati Stevens,
remember that there's a shoot out.
It's only worth that guy.
That's only,
it only gets worse.
I wasn't that guy.
He's one of the best pool player,
especially money players.
That's Keith McCready,
right?
He's a real legit big money player.
Right.
And he was a real unique player because he started playing so young that he
couldn't reach over the table.
So he started playing with his arm,
cocked out to the side,
and he stuck with that forever.
And he was just a world beater,
this guy.
And that's what he used to do.
He used to walk in a pool halls with a shirt that said the world gets the eight.
You know what that means?
That means he spots you in a game,
a nine ball.
He spots you the eight ball.
That means you win the,
if you get the eight ball in or the nine he wins only with
a nine ball.
So he's given professional players.
Yeah,
an advantage.
He's like,
that's how confident he is.
And it was a real guy.
So like when he's playing his Grady,
Steven,
it's like to the people that know the game.
I could,
it's very,
it's very appropriate.
It's perfect.
You know,
that was a,
that movie really represented a lot of the,
the craziness that,
that,
you know,
gambling and pool and being on the road is
none of them ever got it right.
You know what,
I hate all like remakes and especially of classics and,
and the Hustler is such a great fucking film.
It was an excellent follow on of a guy who is just like sitting there in his own
shit.
Just [inaudible] I'm going to come back now.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
Well,
Walter Tevis is a,
a the guy who wrote both of them and he wrote the hustler and he also wrote the
color of money.
But the color of money,
the books,
a very different book.
It's very different ending.
Very different.
It follows fast.
Eddie like on the,
like he goes around by himself.
There's no fence,
there's no Tom cruise character in the product.
They made the comp Tom Cruise character because they wanted to jazz it up for a,
I mean it's a good move for work.
For Pool was a huge,
huge movie.
But uh,
since then video games came along,
kick pool and the deck.
What does that book hard to follow?
I could imagine a pool book be like,
well that's just you though,
cause you're not in pool.
Meaning that they explained like the ball rolled down and you know,
it's not really about pool.
Let's see.
That was the thing about the hustler to you.
Did you ever see that movie?
The hustler long,
long time.
It's really not about pool.
What it's about is about a guy trying to prove that he's worth something in life
and fucking up and making colossal mistakes along the way.
It's about to romantic losers and we connect together and she's a loser,
takes care of it.
And it's got a limp.
I mean there's a lot of dark shit to this movie.
She was a drunk and you know,
Jackie was a drunk,
he's a drunk and Jackie Gleason drunk is a drunk,
I mean these gamblers and,
and,
and fucking murderers and all these people that they were interacting with.
It was so much of,
it was just a character study.
And that was the fascinating thing about that movie.
The pool playing.
Like I said,
it was dog shit.
Paul Newman,
luckily he couldn't make a ball.
Jackie Gleason could play,
he could read,
he could play better than all of them.
Better than Tom Cruise.
Better than Paul Newman.
Paul Newman,
who was just a brilliant actor,
just didn't put the time in.
You would have to put a lot of time in to look like a real pool player,
you know,
cause there's,
there's like a gentleness to the stroke of a real person that is classic Jackie
Gleason.
It really was an amazing cat,
you know,
and an unabashed drinker too.
Like they would ask him like,
why he drinks?
He goes,
I drink to get fucked.
You know what's weird about tech?
I was somewhere recently,
I was in Ghana,
I was in again and doing this a garbage thing that we're doing.
And I watched this old French film,
it's a huge French film,
like successful,
like massive,
like cultural French from the star of the film.
Jackie Gleason.
Wow.
He doesn't say a word.
He plays a mute.
A janitor who picks up a sort of French prostitute and takes care of her and her
young kid.
And it's this French classic film with Jackie Gleason as the star who never says
a fucking word.
And by the way,
it's like a,
Burt Lancaster did the same thing with the Leopard in,
in Italy where I was a huge,
a successful film where he spoke in Italian.
He did it phonetically.
They would just say it into his ear and he'd say the same thing,
but Jackie Gleason was this piece.
No,
no,
no.
They would just say like a gentle famiglia tonight and he would,
and then they roll it to different meetings,
vent unit.
They would just say it in his ear.
You just do it phonetically.
Okay.
There's no earpiece.
So he just repeated it.
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
but Jackie Gleason has this like huge French,
like,
you know,
film like that.
It's like French fucking like cultural where he's the star of it as this janitor
in a,
in a building.
And he didn't,
he never says a word.
When I lived in New York,
I had a friend,
uh,
who,
one of his friends knew the guy's a fucking cock odd connection,
but it was a,
there was,
there were all in music business,
like rock and roll guys.
Like one of them was in this band and he knew a dude who somehow or another new
salon who bought Jackie Gleason's old home and Jackie Gleason.
This is the story.
Jackie Gleason is obviously third hand.
It could be total horseshit and that's it.
The story was,
and it's a fun story,
the Jackie Gleason was drinking with Nixon and him and Nixon were buddies and
that,
you know,
they're talking football and throwing back some fucking Jack and cokes and
Nixon's like you want to see your fucking Ufo so they can,
they get in the Air Force One and they flied some military base where they've
got a crashed flying saucer and Jackie Gleason from Dan on becomes a crazy,
a UFO believer and Jackie Gleason has this backyard and upstate New York and he
has a fake Ufo designed and built in his driveway to replicate the thing that he
saw.
He hires a bunch of people to try to recreate something.
He puts it together and his head sorta like a crime sketch,
like you would try to reenact it.
I want to that want to live story.
That's the fun.
I do believe it.
I would like to find my,
I did fuck up my computer.
It's not working.
Luckily I've got backups.
Spilly makes spiller.
Yeah,
you're drunk already.
Mixed slurs.
Did you get that chemical that you can just put on your computer?
Probably a good idea.
Um,
all right buddy.
But I don't know if Jackie Gleason really did.
Why don't you Google it?
Find out did Jackie Gleason?
Uhh,
really,
really anyone about photos.
It was Jackie Gleason and the UFOS,
it'll say,
well,
Joe Rogan once said,
I spread my own fucking,
I like the PTO isolation.
I like that story.
I'll make up a story not even realizing made it up.
Put it out there and then I'll find it on Wikipedia and I'll use it as a
reference to prove when I tell the story again,
trip to the alien more.
Wow.
So this is a real rumor to the moon,
Alice.
There was a time when you scroll that down,
stop,
go back,
collaborate.
Listen,
stop right there.
You're fucking drunk as shit,
dude.
Uh,
there was another size Jenkins,
extremely serious,
I'm sure UFO researcher and prided himself on the huge collection of [inaudible]
books,
which numbered into the thousands the see I call bullshit.
You know why?
I doubt there's thousands of books written that you have foes back up.
What more could you say?
Like,
Oh,
uh,
you know,
and then he saw light too.
As soon as a new title came out,
even in Europe or the UK,
Jackie had a copy.
Hmm.
Well,
I don't know if it's true.
Um,
but that was the store that this guy told me about the story.
It's a dope story.
If that's true,
if Jackie leasing really was some sort of a crazy UFO fanatic and that that's
even more matching if it's fucking true.
Oh,
it's all true.
What a beautiful thing it would be if they really did have like a hanger.
Yeah.
You know what I want when we're old and we're sitting on the cove drinking our
drink,
looking at the water just mean you gray old silver bags and someone's going to
go,
you know what,
fucking Jackie Gleason went to area 51 and saw that shit.
I wonder what's going to happen.
Yeah.
I wonder.
I wonder who will have,
I wonder if they really do have something.
I mean,
that would be,
I would wish one person who was lid legitimately intelligent who was dying,
which spilled the beans.
I wish every dude that spills the beans,
they're like,
man,
fucking Weirdo.
It just,
I'm not bye bye.
One chive and with my one thing is how impossible would it be to keep a secret
today?
It would be too impossible.
You know,
one person would say something,
I don't agree with that because they look,
they kept a secret when they were making the Manhattan project,
but that was a different era.
What one thing I will say
is maybe those movies and TV shows and leaks and everyone,
because we're all like,
oh yeah,
I already have 51 of course it's the aliens.
Like maybe that's,
you know,
maybe that's part of it.
Look,
we know that secrets can be checked out.
Secrets totally can be kept because we didn't find out about the Gulf of Tonkin
until like way,
way late.
Like there were some people involved in the Gulf of Tonkin incident.
When did it become this term knows look,
30 years,
40 years secrets can be kept,
but nowadays it's,
it's,
it's pretty deep.
Secrets can be kept out.
Wouldn't the most important secret be we found aliens.
That would be like one of the biggest secrets you would ever want to keep.
Like the last thing you want is these motherfuckers just freaking out because
there's aliens.
I like the movies though.
It's just a given.
They're like,
yeah,
well we just got the spaceships from area 51 yeah.
How many movies in that though?
A lot.
Most movies when they try to depict what it would be like if we were attacked.
It's fucking terrible.
I like the fact that we started off with saving democracy and,
well you got drunk along the way and so it shifted to alien power.
Standard Arabic.
Footsie one bitch.
When are you going looking for him?
Come on.
You and dean Kane fucking get up.
He's got that show on spike and I'll do it as it girl ever scored it on you
before.
Are you reading my brain?
Are you part of the MSA?
Is this is?
This is what's happened.
I swines drunk.
The NSA has given you all my information having recently.
All right,
I love you guys.
Wow Brian,
I love you.
Champs.
Brian.
There's something,
one less drink.
Seriously.
Just one last.
Keep it together.
Oh,
diamonds.
What is next for a,
can you remember right now,
if,
uh,
if we shake your memory,
what's next for your show?
Like what do you got going on that we should know about tomorrow night is
Greenland.
Uh,
the world is sinking and a modern day slavery,
David Cho who comes on this show is doing a thing on scrapping,
uh,
which uh,
are metal,
is going to build China.
Um,
this is what we talked about last time you were here I believe.
Yeah.
He's up on the air is up on their next week.
It's a,
they're taking metal from old factories in Detroit and using them to build every
factories in China.
I mean,
but one,
one place where it's really an issue is Detroit.
Yeah.
It's gangs like,
like street gangs.
How we heard about it was like crips and bloods and shit,
we're not going to sell crack anymore cause there's not enough money.
We're going to go steal like copper from old Packard plants in Detroit.
But like Pittsburgh,
Cleveland,
all the rust belt.
And,
uh,
it was a pretty good story until we
figured out who was buying it,
which is China.
So our largest export,
$11 billion a year,
the largest export is scrap from America to China.
Yes.
What's number two?
I have no idea.
Oranges.
Corn.
No,
I dunno how number one by a long way,
number one is crap,
but it's one of those dark things.
They like scrappy.
Joe Finds it out and then hangs out with these Chinese buyers and it's pretty
fucking insane.
It's really good.
Um,
we talked about genetic passports.
Uh,
anyway,
I don't know.
We have a lot of shit coming up.
How many episodes you guys do their year?
12.
Wow.
Uh,
we're probably going to do 24,
actually.
Uh,
now,
now does HBF give you any directorial knows nothing.
Zero.
That's how they do it,
right?
Yeah.
They give you money and he'd go,
Megan,
I've been trying to get you to come do a segment with me for a long time.
That's dangerous and terrible.
We've got to go find that.
Uh,
put a Malibu,
looks for bad plastic surgery.
I'll just,
okay,
you're fine.
The store look for,
you know,
I want to go at and I don't want to go do a story with you,
so,
okay.
What do you want to do?
Like him?
He can't do shit.
No,
no.
I was actually just looking at him,
but thinking of the world of,
of,
of the nation.
Um,
like what kind of a show would you want to do?
I don't know if that means we're done on time.
No,
that's just fried.
He's drunk.
Uh,
what kind of thought?
I thought you would enjoy the fucking north poles or you're out of your mind.
Yeah,
you got me wrong.
You don't want to go get the six foot Chad.
The wrong.
By the way,
you brought up the six foot.
What?
Chimp.
Chimp?
Yeah.
I'm scared of that chimp because the chimps in the middle of the Congo.
So where do you want to do I want to go to Congo.
Cuba.
We'll go,
we'll go interview the Castro and they fucking,
they check your underwear drawer for the rest of your life every time you check
into a hotel.
Correct.
You got real problems.
If you've got a Cuban man,
they look deep up your asshole,
you can't.
And then the last thing you do is go to Cuba and talk about how you're going to
Cuba.
Where were you?
Uh,
I go to Miami with you.
That's about as close second to fucking Cuba.
Yeah.
I'm not a good guy for your show,
Dude.
I'm telling you.
I'm a good guy for you to come on and talk about your show.
I can help you there someday.
I'm going to convince you to come with me.
I'm trying not to do less and less things.
That's my goal.
My goal is to do less shit as I get older.
It just more more shit where I can just know what I see more than anything from
this show is one time when I got wasted as opposed to now,
I was like,
you know what?
We're just trying to get to the fucking cove.
I must get five tweets a day of like I'm trying to get to my cove.
I'm trying to get to my co just trying to,
and by the way,
I just came back from,
uh,
a long trip to an,
a shooting.
I spent three days on a boat in the middle of a cove and I'm like,
I'm trying to get to my cove.
I'm trying to get to my coat.
I just kept repeating that because I'm just trying to get down there,
get to the cove and fucking chill the fuck out.
Well,
I think everybody ultimately has this ideal image in their head of some golden
retirement or some point in time where everything's going to be still,
I don't think ever anything's ever still.
I think you got it.
What I find going to try to get there,
you got to find a balance in the ride itself.
That's where you got to find,
you can't wait for this rest stops.
This is rest stops are bullshit.
That's not happening.
But you have more energy and uh,
like power and in your spine.
I'm an old man.
I'm like,
you know what?
I'm trying to get to the cove.
I know you are.
And I'm not saying that I'm not,
I'm not anti
relaxation.
What I'm saying is that I think if you really did do nothing,
if you always sat somewhere and did nothing,
you would only like it for a few days.
You're right.
You're a guy who likes to investigate things to stimulate your mind and you like
to be a part of something that's bigger than you.
There's a reason why the universe chose you for this role.
I mean that sounds like hippie bullshit.
No,
no,
no.
But I do want to get to the cove.
I'm sure you do down there.
Let's be,
cause you're,
you probably are a little bit imbalanced.
You work so much.
It's probably the,
the cove becomes like this ultimate magnet because you're fucking red lining
shit all day long.
They're trying to sleep with the knowledge of Liberia's general buck naked
running around when he'd killed how many fucking kids and eating their hearts.
Ma,
you know,
you're fucking hitting the gas all day long,
man.
It's,
you need to go down the Peru,
get some Iowasca,
cleanse your soul,
reboot your system.
You've probably seen way too much shit,
man.
Um,
I'm in,
that's why you done with this cove idea.
He might have to scroll so bad.
I was going to build the cove and you are going to come.
Do you ever consider that,
that everybody has like this sort of crazy role in this weird machine that is
life,
this weird complex algorithm that's the human race.
Yeah.
And do you ever wonder why you're in the position that you're in?
No,
but I think that,
I think that everybody,
you're right.
I think that everybody has a sort of role to play in the grand out algorithm of
life.
Uh,
my position,
not really because I don't know about you,
but I'm,
I'm not any different than I was five years ago when no one listened to me.
Right.
And
okay,
you know,
money is the modern day report card and,
and I have a now a lot of money,
but I,
I'm actually giving all that away.
I'm putting it in a trust.
And even because of the,
you're like,
well I didn't,
I didn't actually do it for money.
I don't actually give a shit about money and I didn't actually do it for fame
because I don't know about you.
But like when people come up to you in the street and say,
hey dude,
fucking awesome.
You're like,
I don't know.
I don't,
you know,
I,
I don't know why you,
I don't know anybody on or whatever.
But what I will say is you sit there at some point and go,
this shit,
I spent 40 years turning the other way and saying,
I don't give a fuck or I'm going to just get drunk or I'm gonna drink a beer.
I'm going to go get late or I'm going to fucking do what I do.
Because getting to the day is hard.
And at a certain point you get a little bit older,
you have kids.
For me it was kids and you go,
yeah,
I can't do that anymore.
I got to sit there and say,
this is bullshit.
You know what they're fucking doing over there in Iraq.
It's bullshit is bullshit.
What you're doing here fucking in the Gulf of Mexico is correct and is bullshit.
What did it?
And so now I'm like,
you know what?
I waited for somebody else to fucking say the shit and nobody's saying it and
I'm not the best
person.
And I'll tell you right now,
I'm not the best person to be saying this shit,
but we have to start saying shit.
Otherwise we're fucked.
But you,
you are the best person.
I'm not,
but you're not because you're,
you're look,
no one's the best person,
but you are as bad as good as example as you're going to get because you bridge
the gap.
You were a regular human who lived a regular life,
who got to a point your life where something matter to you much more than it
mattered before when you had children and then you took a stand.
A lot of people would go the other way.
A lot of people when they,
there's the coward point of view is you get to a point where you have children
and then you would just want to shut up.
You just want to be quiet.
You want to,
don't,
don't make a lot of noise.
Know.
Yeah.
All of a sudden you're like,
look,
you could have had the best life ever.
Just keep doing what you're doing.
I could have done the same.
When you have kids,
you're like,
what the fuck dude?
That's when the environment becomes important because you're like,
ah,
okay,
I'm going to die.
It's going to be okay.
Yeah.
There's a certain selfishness there like,
uh,
that a single person will,
um,
for sure.
Um,
it's not even selfishness really.
It's just thinking about yourself.
It's like a natural thing I did that we made being selfish.
You know,
like it doesn't mean you don't think about other people as well.
Like,
so you should be having kids also because I'm selfish because I want my kids to
fucking be able to swim in the lake or go outside.
But is that selfish?
I mean,
is the ultimate my kids,
but isn't the ultimate goal to like see how much you love your kids and say,
man,
if the whole world could love each other the way I love my kids,
we would have no fucking problems.
Any problem we would have,
we would work out.
But isn't the reality that people don't even do anything when they have no,
no strife when they have no,
no thing they're battling against.
They don't really fucking strengthen their resolve.
They don't really get their shit together.
It's like it seems like we,
we almost need resistance in order to get anything done.
We almost need someone to oppose us in order to strengthen ourselves to a
position where we move forward.
I agree and I also think that if left to our own devices,
you're like,
it goes back to that zero sum game.
Like we were talking earlier,
I said about saying what we've gotten to is this real politic is zero sum game.
There isn't a zero sum game when you have kids.
There isn't just there's a winner and loser and I kill you and then you are
dead.
You know when you have kids everything becomes like,
wow,
I won.
But guess what?
They don't have any water to drink.
So I dunno.
I shifted,
my whole brain shifted when I had kids because I was a different guy and then
all of a sudden I have kids and I was like,
actually motherfucker,
I already knew that that was bullshit.
What you were doing.
I knew fucking,
you know,
$78,000 hammers were bullshit,
but I used to go seven,
$8 fucking hour and now I'm like,
no,
fuck you.
$78,000 hammers.
Bullshit.
I don't want to fucking pay my texted for that shit.
And I just got angry because all the bad shit,
all this stuff that you roll your eyes,
all the shit you say,
you know this is fucking bullshit.
This is stupid.
We shouldn't be doing this.
I got serious because then you're like,
okay,
it's fine.
Guess what?
Climate change is undeniable.
The fucking oceans are rising or you want to have a debate,
you want to have a fucking war.
You want to the fact that it's even a debate is it fucking joke.
And guess what?
We don't have the time anymore because our kids are fucked.
So guess what?
I can't fuck around anymore.
Snort coke all night,
fucking wear my fancy jeans and get wasted.
I got to go out there and fight these motherfuckers because otherwise my kids
don't have a fucking future.
And,
and by the way,
not my kids,
everyone's kids.
Did you see that
NASA report when they,
uh,
they,
they looked at climate change and a bunch of different factors and they were
talking about the future of the human race.
They made this extrapolation and I'm like,
we're doomed
now.
If you talk to most scientists,
and like by the way,
real scientists,
not these dudes in the pay of Exxon,
it's,
it's like a given.
This is why I get pissed off is because I'm like,
you know,
who's,
who's done a bad job is the scientific community at,
at messaging the fact that,
okay,
if there's a fucking loophole,
if there's like,
well it's this or this within 6% and then everybody else goes,
well,
6% is this and this is when you're like,
hold on a second.
We are 60 years ahead of our worst case projections,
the worst case projection of the EPCC 10 years ago.
We're already 60 years of fucking head,
60 years head.
And I,
I was talking to the global scientific community,
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Why doesn't anyone know about this?
But you guys are like,
well,
it's a given.
It's not a given with anyone.
I know most people have no idea.
No.
They just go to work and they hear bad things about the economy.
But then they hear 150,000 new jobs were created last quarter.
What's happening in California?
So it says Nasa Bay,
NASA back study says human civilization is headed for irreversible collapse.
Yes.
According to the new NASA.
I don't know what that means by NASA back study.
It sounds very fancy,
but I'm going to show you understand masses like conservative,
like there's scientists that,
those are crazy for sure.
Right?
Like when,
whenever I talked to,
uh,
to,
scientists,
I tried to get the most conservative motherfuckers cause they,
you know,
they're gonna come after you.
But the thing is,
is what's happening now is we are on route for a global cataclysmic
environmental catastrophe.
And everyone agrees to that.
Right?
Everyone,
right.
But we're,
why aren't we trying to stop it?
Do you think there's
any way that something can be done along the way that we never saw common that
could fix the whole thing?
Yes.
What do you think that could be?
Possibly be?
So this is probably bullshit,
but I was at the Google Zitgeist conference.
There was this kid,
I tell you this story before he starting years old,
he builds a reactor and his,
uh,
did I tell you this guy?
I believe so,
but it's a great story.
You've gone,
okay.
So he blew me away.
He built a reactor when he was 13,
17.
He came up with a way to find radioactive way.
Anyway,
so he came up with this theory,
which is true that 90% of uranium,
uranium isotopes,
you know,
two or 35 et Cetera,
which we can't dispose of,
the majority of their energy is still left in there over 90%.
So he's like,
okay,
we,
we've come up with these reactors where we can take the old energy rods that we
can't even dispose of,
uh,
deplete them.
And then that will fuel the earth's energy needs for the next 10,000 years
because all of those energy rods from the Soviet Union,
from us,
uranium two to 35,
we can all do it now.
Maybe not true,
he's 23 years old.
I don't know.
But if that's even like 0.0,
zero zero 1% true that he can take all the shit that we can't even dispose of
and power the world with it.
Fuck yeah,
that's technology right now.
I don't know if that's true,
but I'm hoping for some sort of technological solution.
Well,
I'm hoping along the way he doesn't create something even more fucked up while
he's trying to rainium which might happen fucking hole.
I don't know.
But what I'm hoping is for some tech solution that comes along to say,
because you know what the other alternative is?
We're fucked.
Yeah.
I think the tech people are our brightest hope.
They seem to be self policing.
I mean,
look at the big companies like Google,
you know,
like they,
they,
they actually,
you know,
they spend a lot of money on their employees.
They kind of had global ethics,
you know,
I mean when at least they try.
Yeah.
You don't think of an evil company at all.
At least they try.
Yeah.
You've,
you've,
you know,
you hear that there's some issues with NSA censorship in certain countries and
things along those lines,
but when you connect Google,
you connect them to the idea of a giant corporation that's committed to
innovation.
They don't seem bad or not Exxon,
but you know,
that seems to be like something that you find more of in the tech community.
And I think it's because you're dealing with some really hyper intelligent human
beings and along with that hyper intelligence and that connection to each other
that they have,
because the Internet,
I think you see people that have like a better moral compass.
They're also trying to solve global problems
by using technology.
No,
I don't,
you know,
I'm not good at technology,
but you're awesome attitude.
You have vice.com how dare you.
If I had the ability to figure out the world's energy problems by depleting old
uranium rods.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
It seems like a good move.
Seems like a good dude.
Did we run out of Shit?
I love you.
We never want to shift to talk about.
We just want to love you.
I love you too,
buddy.
It's fun.
You're hammered.
I have to go to bed.
You should probably go to bed.
I love you.
Joe Rogan,
death squad,
red ban.
Shane Smith,
vice.com uh,
Shane Smith 30 on Twitter.
Send him some love.
Send me Love on Shane Smith.
30th Twitter.
Go to vice dot.
If you've never seen anything,
start with the story on Liberia.
What's the Liberia one called?
Then go with vice travels about that dude who lives up in the middle of fucking
nowhere in the Yukon and lives by himself high Mo's Arctic adventure.
Oh,
North Korea.
That's how I,
that's a great one too.
I found out about vice from Heine Mo.
What a great story,
but you guys have awesome contact.
Joe Rogan.
I love you buddy.
Did you have sex again when you're asked content?
Best content online.
Hello,
vice.com.
Uh,
thanks to our sponsor,
ting,
go to rogan.ting.com save 25 bucks off of any of their cell phone devices.
Thanks.
Also do on at.com go to o,
n N.
I t used the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all sub elements.
We'll see you guys next week.
Much love.
Have a good weekend.
Big Kiss.
Bye Bye.